You guys hear that?
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the brain.
That's how hard it's raining here.
All these posts he's telling you,
don't,
don't mow your lawn.
Don't move.
Don't water the lawn.
Don't feel the pool.
We're run out of water.
We're running out of water here in
California.
Not Anymore.
Motherfucker.
It's theirs.
They're evacuating people.
Jamie,
what did,
what did it say on your phone?
Evacuate.
Sacramento's fucked the dam is blowing.
Frank is steal the damn.
Uh,
I usually don't introduce guests,
but this gentlemen across me here is,
uh,
I'm really proud of you.
Thank you.
Frank.
Istio if you go to his instagram page,
let me just tell everybody.
He just one roast battle on comedy
central,
which,
uh,
with standup Comedians,
that's a huge deal.
I mean that is,
that's a big deal.
That shows a big deal.
It's a big deal for comedy,
but it's a big deal.
You want.
And if you go to your instagram page,
dude,
it's so inspirational.
You do.
The shittiest fucking shows are out
there doing bowling alleys.
You're out there doing like bars with
three people in them and you're doing
three,
four a night.
You're just always hammering it.
I love it.
And then to see you do that and to see
you working at the store like many other
people before like Dunkin's done like
Ari's done.
Like rent is easy.
He's done.
Like so many people have gone from
working at the store.
Bobby Lee I think worked at the store.
Yep.
So many people have gone from working in
the store to making it as a comic to so
to see you go from working at the store,
grinding every night and then Winnie
Rose Battle show,
these motherfuckers that trophy here
too.
Dude.
It's fucking heavy.
Feel that's legit as fuck to him now.
I get why they don't want people to hand
those out like the second I got it.
I was like,
I get why they,
I get it now.
They shouldn't just hand these out the
kits.
It's so powerful.
Yeah.
You can't just give a kid a trophy for
nothing.
You got to win.
You've got to do it.
And that this show roast battle is one
of the reasons why I came back to the
comedy store.
When I went to see our,
he was doing his a special and he had
decided to film his first comedy central
special at the store.
And I hadn't been in the soar in seven
years.
I hadn't even stepped foot inside of the
place.
And I was like,
well,
there's no way I'm missing this.
So I had a,
had a bite,
the bullet,
I had to go in there.
And um,
I said,
well,
let me just go the night before.
And uh,
Jeff Ross asked me to be one of the
judges that roast battle.
And so I was sitting up there and I was
going,
wow,
this is crazy.
This is a totally different thing.
Like this was never here seven years
ago.
There was nothing,
anything like it.
It was like really creative writing,
really like nasty jokes.
But then everybody's hugging afterwards,
you know,
like that's the one,
like one of the rules is like,
after you do it,
you got to hug it out.
Like it was fucking great.
And I was like,
creatively,
this is so inspiring.
And it's so,
there's so much life to it that,
and then our specialist had fucking them
back.
It was a,
it's a crazy thing man.
I mean it was just also just having you
show up and just be a part of that.
That was one of those things where like
everyone knew like all the younger
comics,
all the open makers,
cause it started as an open mic.
So when we saw you come in ever,
it was just like,
oh this is different.
Like that's when everyone kind of was
like,
oh things are changing.
Yeah.
Man,
things have changed since then.
At the store.
The store is a crazy place now.
It's insane.
Like I've been there,
I started there in 94 and uh,
it was uh,
kind of like,
there's something that happened before I
got there.
Like a bomb had gone off and like these
are,
the survivors had just moved back to the
city.
It was weird.
It was like the age of kinison had died,
you know,
the,
and then there was really no one after
him.
So like I came in the early nineties and
kinison was like 80,
you know,
like the early eighties to like 86,
88.
And then I believe he died in like what
did he die in like 1992 or something
like that.
He'd already left the store and um,
when I got there it was all these weird
road comics that were like boat acts,
Bowtech's boat acts,
you know to boat act is someone who does
a lot of cruise ships.
No disrespect to anybody.
Does cruise ships.
I know there's a lot of comics who
really do love doing cruise ships and
they're really funny comics.
There's,
that's not what I mean.
But what I mean is like there's,
there was certain people that didn't
work anywhere else but like really
shitty gigs and there was a lot of them
at the store and I was like,
this is so weird.
I thought it was going to be like
Richard Pryor and you know Louie
Anderson.
I thought it was just going to be killer
after killer after killer.
It wasn't like that.
But it is now.
This is the time.
It is.
Some of those lineups are the absolute
craziest,
like it's ridiculous.
Chris Taleah Bill Burger,
like what?
Over and over again.
This killer after killer of to kill her
Moshe Kasher.
Joey Diaz.
What the fuck man,
Tasha was air.
All those guys going up.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Andrew Santino boom,
boom,
boom.
It's like kill or after killer young
killers.
Older killers.
It's crazy.
Ron White is there now just walking
around.
It's the,
it's,
it's actually insane with us in that
back bar.
Yeah.
The elder statesmen of standup comedy.
I remember when Ron White came into a
casino I was working at,
I was just,
it was before I moved to Los Angeles for
anything.
I was just working in the bar and he was
doing a show there and I remember I was
just like,
oh my God,
I can't believe it's Ryan White.
Yeah.
Matt and I talked to him and then now
it's just so crazy to be like at the
comedy store is sitting in the back
smoking a joint just talking to him
about comedy
dude.
And you know what?
And we started doing the factory again
too.
We did the factory last week and we're
going to do it again next week.
We're going to do the factory on
Wednesday nights.
Every other Wednesday at 10 o'clock.
Yeah,
man.
Because the factory was struggling and
we were like,
the factory is a good
club.
It's just,
you know,
it had a lot of weirdness in the past
that was connected to it and the store
was always that place to go to.
So like,
I think it's important when we see these
clubs that were really lucky to have
that we support them all.
Absolutely.
You know,
keep them going.
It's cause it's guys like you,
these guys that are coming up,
like you're,
you're going to be in the same position
that we're in some day where you're,
you know,
you're,
you're capable of like organizing a
night and fill up a room and then it
pumps up the business.
And then guys like you get in,
you know,
like when we did the ice house Wednesday
night,
you know,
guys like you get in and then you'll be
in that same position someday too.
It's fucking cool to watch,
man.
Yeah,
it's absolutely just insane to be a part
of,
you know what I mean?
Cause it's like doing,
I got to host when we were at the laugh
factory that Wednesday and that was
bananas cause it was just like meeting
the booker and the manager and all these
people and again sick lineup.
Yeah.
And it's just crazy.
I know you're getting in your,
you're like at the door.
You're,
it's,
I remember those days man,
wasn't it?
I know it was never in a position like
you're in though.
Like your position is better than my
position when I was in like your,
your stages of standup because you got
into something through standup.
I got into something through a Sitcom,
like a sitcom was like it's okay but
it's not the same.
Like the standup route is the best
route.
It's really odd too because of like just
how many people have seen the roast
battle.
Like just the finals.
Like I almost,
I almost feel naive because I didn't
realize how many people were there.
Like it was like winning the combine of
like at the NFL combine,
but for comedy it was,
dude,
it was a big deal.
It was a big deal.
It was like guys at the store and girls,
I shouldn't be sexist guys.
The girls and girls at the store.
Um,
we were following it like a sports team.
Like we're following it.
Yeah.
I like,
it was crazy.
I was like,
who's in the lead?
Who's winning?
Where's he at?
You know?
Yeah.
And just the vibe in the room was
absolutely crazy.
Just like hearing,
it was like a sporting event.
It was nuts,
dude.
When I showed up at the store after
you'd won,
it was like,
like we were super bowl champs.
Yes,
Tracy.
It was,
people were like crying,
like other comp,
but also me winning was such a weird
thing cause it was like,
especially the La comedy community,
I don't wanna say like open miker is
like,
it's a terrible term,
but it's like I'm still an open mic or
you know what I mean?
Like I still hit open mics comic that
does these things.
So it's like when I won,
I had see all these guys that I would
see at these open mics and there was
just like,
it was like we want,
you know what I mean?
Cause it's like they see me at all these
spots,
they know me as the guy that's always
working at the store that's always doing
something.
So it was like a weird sense of pride.
It was like your home team,
but it's also,
it shows you that you can do it.
Like there you,
you're them,
you guys are all working together.
You're all doing those open mics
together.
They know there's,
there's nothing like you didn't get some
Willy Wonka golden ticket and somebody
lets you in.
No,
he just hammered it out,
man.
You kept doing it.
You were instagram pages.
That shit man.
I really do draw inspiration from it.
I'd love seeing,
and I know you're funny too,
which helps.
Thank you.
Let's a certain people that I look at
and I go,
well this is this guy or this
girl.
All they have to do is not fuck this up
to funny like you got it.
Yeah.
And it's like,
it's very important to tell those people
that to like sell them.
You you can do,
cause I remember people saying that to
me and it was a shoot like Mark Marin
gimme a speech one day after I,
uh,
did a show at
the comedy connection in Boston,
which was this little tiny room and he
said some cool shit to me after my set
and I was still raw,
open miker like way rar even than you.
I was like,
how long have you been doing it now?
Uh,
started one was 21.
So I'd say about 27 hours to six years.
But like,
seriously for four,
which is like the pace that I've been
doing it where I'm like hitting my is
trying to go on shows.
I'm really taking it seriously.
Is it harder to do
get cracking in La,
do you think?
Because there's so much comedy here?
I don't think it's hard to get cracking.
I think it's tougher definitely.
But I think if you're willing to work
hard because you're surrounded by,
this is something my manager told me
right before I moved because I was
supposed to get a job and then I didn't
and I was really better and I wanted to
move to Los Angeles and he said,
you can move now and find out you're the
shit and things are going to go great,
or you could move now and find out
you're not the shit and then work really
hard and then get really good.
And that's what I did.
It's like a good manager.
That's good.
Solid manager.
He was,
I mean he was a,
it was a restaurant manager,
but I mean it was great advice.
Wow.
So he doesn't have anything to do with
comedy?
No,
he was just a mall that day.
Come to start an agency.
That's why it was so logical.
That's why what he said was so logical.
You never hear that from fucking standup
comedy managers.
They give people the worst advice,
but that's what I did.
I moved here and then it was like,
you know,
people were just like,
oh,
there's no time in Los Angeles.
It's like,
no,
there's time.
If you're willing to make it,
like I will drive to have mike sign up,
drive to another mic,
sign up,
drive back to that first.
Mike hit a spot tech.
Someone that's running a show or a house
that I know is going to just toss me up
at the end so I know I could go to that
Mike in two and a half hours while I'm
waiting for this other mic.
So it's like,
it's just like,
how much are you willing to pay for gas?
You know what I mean?
Like you,
it's really,
you're investing in yourself.
Yeah.
Well you are.
You're right.
You're also,
you're,
you're definitely investing in yourself,
but you,
you're growing in some weird way.
Like when the more sets you do,
your act just kind of grows.
Like sometimes I've done the hat trick
at the store,
we do the main room,
the belly room,
and then the aor or what,
whatever order.
By the time you get to that third show,
dude,
you're on fire,
you're just ready to have fun.
We just talked and in the groove and
that's where a lot of times new ideas
come from because you're so comfortable
on stage.
Like maybe you're working on a new pit
and out of nowhere this new angle comes
up and it's the best angle of the bed.
It's cause it's just something you've
said.
Yeah,
like offhand
saw something super satisfying.
It's about seeing someone work hard and
become successful.
I love seeing people succeed.
I can seeing like someone work hard and
then it actually working and then you
see all these people that come up with
excuses and they're always fucking off
and not,
they're not traveling enough,
they're not doing enough sets and not
writing enough.
They're sticking with the same old
material for too long,
you know,
come on man.
And now it's different because it's like
I'm in a weird position where it's like
most people when something like that and
then we'll turn off their hour or
something.
It's like me,
I'm just a I,
you know,
I'm a door guy so I've got like 15 maybe
20 good minutes.
But now's the opportunity for me,
like people ask me to headline somewhere
like some random club.
I was like,
I'm not going to do that.
Like I'll do 20 minutes sets for the
next year and a half to build that hour
cause I just want to be a good college.
You definitely have to get frantic now
about creating new material and that's
something about those really short sets.
Like a lot of times open mikes,
they give you three minutes,
you know,
what do you get three,
sometimes five and then sometimes for
some people giving me a little bit
longer just because you know,
but that's,
it's hard to
come on like that for me.
That's like the setup for a bit
sometimes.
You know,
like you're just getting your,
you're just getting the whole sort of
landscape laid out before you go into a
bit.
Kennison used to say that that was a big
thing about Kennison not liking to do a
late night shows.
He's just like,
I can't get cooking in five minutes.
You know,
because he was used to doing those.
He would take the late spot at the store
where he would just go as long as he
wanted.
He would have that last spot.
The kinison spot.
Yeah.
I mean that's what we call it today.
We call it the Kennison spot.
I've never done it.
Maybe I'd done it like two or three
times,
but I mean,
I haven't done it in like recent years
at all.
I got to do one super late spot.
It was the first time I worked a potluck
and usually at the rules of,
um,
the store,
once you first get hired,
you don't get on friends and family
lists for a few months.
It's something you have to earn a,
that's when I was working there.
So it was like for the first four months
you didn't get any spots you had to keep
working there.
And then eventually the Tachyon potluck
and then if you're good enough to put
you on the name or you put your name on
the list so you have to get up.
So it was my first night working
potluck.
It's one 30 in the morning and the host
is about to finish the show.
And I'm talking to one of the guys,
I'm like,
Hey,
I,
you know,
I just got hired here.
I haven't gotten up.
There's still two people here.
There's no paid regulators.
Can I just go up at the end,
do like three or five minutes?
And the manager's looking at,
I was like,
whatever,
go ahead.
And then,
yeah,
I got to go up three minutes.
Did like potluck at one 30 in the
morning in front of two people.
And that was like the most funniest I've
ever had.
Well,
it's,
you're realizing like,
Holy Shit,
I'm on stage at the comedy store.
Yeah.
That alone.
I'm actually behind a mic in front of an
audience at the comedy store where
everyone else has been that's been
falling these exact same footsteps.
Yeah.
You know,
this is a conversation that I had,
um,
the other day with a another comedian.
We were talking about how there's
certain actors,
especially I think actors who will treat
people,
um,
that are like what they call below the
line,
like producers and people who are extras
and people who are,
you know,
um,
they're,
they're not caterers,
things like that.
They're not the PR,
they're not,
they're not the executives and they're
not the big top people and the other
actors.
So they treat them one way and then the
rest of the folks that work on the set a
different way.
Like those people are not equal.
They're,
they're like below the line.
And we were talking about how with stand
up everybody at the store is pretty much
like once you working there and once
we,
your people like you and you're cool,
we're all the same thing.
Yeah.
Like you get that like,
like whether it's Daniel Tosh or you
know,
Bill Burr,
like they'll talk to you like everybody
talks to you that like everybody's the
same because we all know that we are
that person.
Like everybody,
like everybody work in the door that has
dreams to become a standup is like me
when I was delivering newspapers or
driving limos,
same thing.
We're all the same thing.
Yeah
it's Angela crazy too.
Cause it's like,
I mean working at the store,
I mean you put a great point,
like there's definitely a moment where
headliners start taking you seriously
and then treat you like a peer and that
is an awesome moment and just like,
it's interesting right when it happens.
Like I remember when like you know,
you first started talking to me or like
Jessel knicker like Jeff Ross first like
gave me attention just to like talk and
like I could hold their attention like
we like it felt like we were peers and
that's just insane feeling to have as a
young comic for the first time.
Well that's part of the scary thing
about,
I think it was probably any,
any endeavor,
whether you're,
you want to become a,
an artist or a surgeon or whatever the
fuck you want to become.
If you have people that you see that are
ahead of you that are already doing it,
it seems like the barrier between you
and them as insurmountable and sometimes
just someone saying something to you,
just someone saying,
look,
everybody starts out as a beginner.
There's no instant experts know.
You start out as a beginner,
you don't know what the fuck you're
doing and then eventually you figure it
out.
So everyone you see that is up there.
That is,
that's you.
We're all the same thing.
It's just people,
people in the people that are further
ahead.
You kind of have an obligation to go,
hey,
if you liked the art form,
and I love the art form.
I think stand up comedy is like my still
my favorite thing to watch.
How all these years of doing it.
You want more people to succeed.
Oh yeah.
You know,
so this is,
I think there's a greed thing that some
folks possess where they only want to
shine.
They want to be the only person who
shines.
So they,
these people coming up,
they're like fucked up.
I mean I'm going to keep these fuckers
down.
Just my boot motherfucker.
You know there's,
there's some of that,
you know,
where they're trying to kick you as
you're trying to climb up behind him.
I've experienced that a few times but I
was,
oh my mom always told me and my dad too,
my mom always said it was one of the
things we were just like,
you treat everyone the way you want to
be treated.
And also you also got to remember,
it's like,
it's like you have to be nice to have
because you never know who's going to be
who you know.
Well you should just be nice cause it
feels good too.
Yeah.
And it's also feels good to them.
Feels good to you.
When I go,
sorry,
when I go on home and Mike's and I
always make sure to tag all the guys
running the mix.
Always make sure to say thank you and
stuff.
Cause it's like,
you know,
I'm not the only one and you always got
to try to take care of the people and
bring them up in that cool little
network of social media.
You know of tagging peoples instagrams
and you know,
and letting people know like
on Tuesday nights,
great show,
like all that stuff helps,
helps everybody,
helps the community.
It helps uh,
people who are comedy fans,
like if you're a comedy nerd,
Holy Shit,
what a good town to live in.
Oh absolutely crazy.
And you,
a lot of them,
you see him like come
to the store and sometimes it's like
unnerving because you know,
they've seen your act and you're working
on these new beds.
Like,
oh bitch,
you already seen it's been,
you feel like such a fraud.
That's how I feel every time I go up
with the rose back because I got to go
up every Tuesday at the roast battle.
Then before it was just like audiences
who kind of like have seen the rose pose
to the fans of it.
But now it's like,
this is the first week where people came
to see me.
Like they were just like,
oh my God,
we know who you are.
And Moses who runs a show and coach t
both just,
they were like,
you're,
you're here to see frank.
It was like a black couple to,
they're like black people like frank,
this is crazy.
But it was just not.
And so,
but now it's like there's a pressure
every Tuesday for me to do something
new,
to write something new.
You've got to ramp it up,
but you're still working at the store to
you.
I saw you had pictures of you sweeping
up after a roast battle.
That's a great feeling too.
I had to put in my two weeks,
sort of like my almost two weeks we'll
get you up there.
You had to put in my,
I had to tell my boss,
I was like,
listen,
I love working here,
but I'm just getting too busy at nights.
Like I can only work phones.
And then I was like,
I gotta go dude,
you know,
standup stuff.
And they were super cool.
They were like,
that's great.
We're really happy for you.
And that just shows that the system's
working at the store.
It's the only place that I know of that
really has that system where the
employees are all comics.
They're all so it's so weird to fun
place to work because of that.
It's the best man.
I mean there's no,
I mean in that picture too,
it's one those things where it's like
someone called me and was like,
can you work phones?
And I was like,
yeah,
I'll work phones.
So I worked phones and then I sat in the
main room because someone couldn't make,
cause someone was out of town,
sway sat the shift and then every,
and then I had to help with the roast
battle cause they do that anyways.
It's just part of my job.
So it was like I did all these things
and then I got to do a set and then I
got to judge the roast battle and Tasi
jokes out.
Cause when I judge,
I mostly just write jokes so I can just
say funny things while I'm,
and then we'll let everyone else do like
the critiques and stuff.
It's also like who am I?
Right.
But I just an opportunity for me to
shine and make funny jokes at the people
battling.
But I mean it,
it's all just in today's work,
you know,
it's all just work.
Well that's the thing about that roast
battle show that's really interesting is
that it's really a joke writer showcase
because everything has to be new.
You,
there's no,
you can't use stock jokes and you are,
you're essentially giving an assignment.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
hey Frank Castillo,
this is,
you know,
Bob Smith and you know,
you've got to figure out what's fucked
up about Bob Smith's head.
That one joke he said about that dude,
it will do,
is it his forehead?
Joe's forehead?
Uh,
Joe's foreheads,
Joe's forehead.
It looks like it added a second story on
it.
So it'd be more room to think about
dicks.
That kind of shit.
Cause it do,
did have a large forehead,
but like that's something that you have
to think up about that person.
And if you make a regular forehead joke
and it's not going to be like,
it's like,
oh okay cool.
Yeah,
he's got a big forehead,
whatever.
But if you make it and add layers,
do what it's more funny.
Yeah.
And he really is a set up punchline
format.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's it really funny format because it's
a blah
blah,
blah is so blah blah blah.
You know,
you can't,
there's no ranting.
There's no you really,
you only,
you can't go on rants also because
you're really only supposed to be
allowed one line.
I can sometimes people cheat and they'll
throw like two and three in wwe.
That's,
that's the cool thing about it.
It's like,
it's almost like boxing.
That's the beauty of the roast battle
show is like,
it's not only writing,
it's also performance and it's like the
last,
especially in the finals,
you can see where like I do some crazy
shit and then it's also,
that's something I learned from Mike
Lawrence and the season one where Mike
Lawrence,
season one,
he was one of the only guys to be,
to start the,
thank you blah blah blah,
and then go into the joke and then hit
them again.
So it was like,
so it's fitting a rebuttal in new your
setup.
And then this season I did something new
where it was like,
I knew that if people hit me with the
looks like joke,
they were going to stop and wait for the
laughter and then do the rest of their
joke.
So in my mind I was like,
if I hit them quick with a better looks
like joke,
it'll take the momentum out of that last
joke.
And now it just depends on this joke to
create the momentum.
Right.
So it's like you're playing chess up
there and it's like boxing.
Like it was,
it looks like jokes or just quick jabs
and then your big,
big jokes are you're like an haymakers.
Yeah.
There's some mean shit that gets said to
all my God.
Like some soul searing shift gears
survive.
But you will be scarred.
You know,
some people are really bro,
but fucking hilarious.
It's a weird art form.
It's a totally different day.
You know,
like this whole roast battle things a
totally different thing than regular
standing up.
But
Oh yeah.
Regular standup is in it.
Cause you still have to like perform.
That's why I like that last battle.
Me and Rashard was so good.
Cause prostart is one of the funniest
dudes I know.
He's a great writer,
super cool dude and an amazing rose
bachelor.
But it's like when you're in that
situation and there's just so much
pressure because it's like you're
getting made fun of,
you have to memorize these jokes because
they had us memorize the two guys.
We pot the guy we were going against and
the two possible winners of the other
bracket.
Oh how much time did you have to write
these bits?
Uh,
so it was think five days,
five days.
You had to write five jokes for jokes.
The first guy,
one possible over time.
And then the finals was five jokes.
One possible over time.
So six trips.
So total you're writing 1820 jokes,
not including your looks like or your
quick rebuttals.
Holy Shit.
That's a lot of work.
Yeah.
And Are you taking like these five out
of a pile of like 20 or 30 like how many
jokes you're actually writing before you
narrow it down?
Usually if it's like for the TV thing,
like it was a,
they let us,
like I had my cut man,
which is like my boy Dan Nolan.
He helps you with strategy.
Oh Yay.
That's what they did.
Season One,
two.
Well that's what they want to do cause
it's like in the finals they want it to
be a great show.
So for me it wasn't like he was riding
me jokes.
It was like we both sat down and I wrote
a bunch of premises and a bunch of
angles and we talked strategy and then
we went from there.
Cause it was like if I'm going to make
fun of Joe,
I can't just be making many gay jokes,
I'm going to get dinged for that.
But it's like he's,
that's such a big characteristic of how
he is and how he walks and just like how
he holds himself that it's like you
can't not make jokes about that.
Right.
So it was like if I make jokes about it,
I have to be silly and it has to come
from like a child like ignorance,
you know what I mean?
So I cannot like call him like
like a faggot or something like superman
or anything.
I just got it like,
but I could say it was like he loves but
stuff.
You know what I mean?
Like that's just funny and childlike,
you know.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Like there's a tone that you have to set
where you,
you can't be too mean.
No because while you're,
even while you're saying really mean
Shit Zack,
cause you can lose the crowd.
Yeah.
But if you can gain their trust to the
point where you've said so many silly
funny things,
that's where at the end you can really
earn saying something terrible.
But as long as it's fun.
Now is it weird to be doing these rows
battles where you're writing all this
new stuff every week,
but then when you're doing standup
you're doing a lot of stuff that you've
already done before?
Yeah.
It is weird in the sense that it's like,
it's making me realize that the
different like that I can just,
I can create new material.
You know what I mean?
Because especially in high pressure
situations,
but it's like if I give,
if I have a goal or a set a set time,
like I can write new material and now
what I'm realizing is like I can just do
that with my standup.
If I can do that with Rose Battle where
I sit down and write all these jokes,
I can do that with writing packets.
I can do that with my standup and it's
just getting up and just doing it.
You know what I mean?
Where's that book?
Yeah.
This book is the shit after.
People are getting mad at me now from
for suggesting this book so much,
but it's called the war of art.
It's by this Guy Steven Pressfield.
And it's essentially about overcoming
what he calls resistance,
what most people call procrastination.
Oh yeah.
You know that overcoming this,
whatever it is that keeps you from
actually putting in the work.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And he talks about it and he sort of
identifies it and then it gives you
tools to deal with it and explains how
it affected him.
He was essentially just not doing well
at all.
And his life until he was about 40 and
then at 40,
kind of got his shit together and now
he's just a award winning author and uh,
written a bunch of great movies and a
bunch of great books.
He's just very inspirational stuff.
But that,
that's what I was kind of getting at.
It's like,
I think that now that you're in this new
spot where everybody knows who you are
or you won the Rose Battle,
you've got all this heat on you.
It's like super important now to take
all that writing to the next level.
Absolutely.
Like,
I mean I thought it was busy now herb
before just grinding,
writing these jokes.
Now it's like,
like I walked into levity and the
manager knew me,
like everyone kind of knows who I am in
a sense,
you know what I mean?
Not that I'm like,
Oh,
I'm famous on this.
They just know that I did this thing and
then there's a window.
He's got to jump through that window,
you know,
because some people miss that window and
it's weird.
You'll run into guys that were on last
comic standing a long time ago and they
had a window where things were happening
for them and then it blew away and they
never capitalize.
They never jumped through it.
And then some guys like Ralphie may who
jump through it running,
you know,
Ralphie may probably worked harder than
anybody after that show was that he was
cranking out dvds,
tour in everywhere.
And uh,
he capitalized phenomenally on his time
on the show,
but other people just did not,
they just never really,
never really got a cooking.
But you are,
um,
you know,
you're,
you're like in a great spot like right
now.
Yeah.
And that's,
for me,
it's like,
I don't plan on stopping.
Like I want to do as many sets as I can.
I'll do it.
I'll still do someone's Quincenera for
20 bucks.
Like,
I'll do it.
You really,
man,
get ready.
I'll do whatever,
man.
It's just to have a fake continue era
just to have you over for 20 bucks,
man.
Okay.
One roast battle.
No Mexicans here.
Um,
yeah,
I mean but it's just like,
I mean I just want to do stand up.
This is my favorite thing.
Especially like I do,
it does suck that I'm not going to be at
the store as much working there cause
that was one of my favorite things was
just sitting working the door and just
watching all the comics go up.
Cause I really believe the store is a
comedy college.
Yeah,
no it definitely is.
But you graduated from high school and
now you're a moved on into university
life.
Oh,
it's insane.
Yeah.
It's cool.
It's really cool.
This,
this store right now,
um,
I think is a wonderful place for you to
come back to when you're doing other
shows and then start doing shows there
as a paid regular,
you know,
once you showcasing it through.
Yeah,
I showcased once.
Um,
and I can't wait to showcase again.
I think we were talking about this
earlier.
It's like a lot of people come up to me
asking me like,
are you going to be a paid regular?
It was one of those things where it's
like,
I want to,
but I want it when it,
when I feel I've earned it and I deserve
it.
I want to get it just because of
something.
Yeah.
Dude.
The funny shit that you wrote on roast
battle,
you could do that all day day.
You could do that all day about,
you can just like pick subjects,
you know,
like Rose Trump.
Did you see that new thing that came out
today that,
I mean,
not yesterday,
that crazy rant that he went on that
press conference for an hour and a half
people,
people that are friends of mine that are
conservatives are scared.
Like I have some buddies of mine that
were like,
dude,
this ain't good.
Like he seems unstable.
Oh yeah,
he's going crazy.
My favorite are the people that look at
it and they're just like,
no,
that's totally cool.
No,
totally fine.
These people were out of their mind.
There was a reporter who,
um,
did you see that one reporter,
a Jewish reporter when he tried to shut
him down?
So to sit down?
No,
no,
the reporter that,
um,
he was talking about what kind of a
landslide he won the electoral college
by,
and then it's the greatest landslide
ever.
And this guy was like,
absolutely not that April out the stats.
Yeah.
I pulled up the stats.
Everybody did better.
Obama did better.
George Herbert Walker did better.
George W did better.
They all did better.
Yeah,
I think it was the guy from CNN and then
he ended up calling him CNN.
He's like,
God,
now I got a new name for them.
It's very fake news.
Well,
I don't know if it's that guy.
It's on Patton Oswalt's twitter page.
He retweeted it that someone said about
calling
him out on his lies because he says what
the,
you know,
that he won by the biggest landslide
ever.
And then this other guy comes in like
someone who,
who's that overt with their ego.
Like that's never been a part of the
White House before.
It's,
it's so strange to see.
And I just,
I think that it seems like already
that's wearing on him.
Oh yeah.
It's like a crazy person.
You could see it.
He,
it's,
he's unraveling,
you know what I mean?
And it's also like the people he's got
around him,
you know,
it,
they're not helping him at all.
He's out a blunt with tobacco on the
outside.
Yes.
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
I'm a big fan of blondes.
I only started smoke.
I only smoke these a couple of times,
but Charlie Murphy got me on this.
Oh Man.
When I grown up in San Jose,
my cousins,
all they did was smoke weed and one of
it was like a thing with him.
Whenever I'd roll a blunt,
he'd get mad at me if it,
if it wasn't as full as possible.
He get mad.
Yeah.
He'd be like,
dude,
there's too much tobacco I can take.
And then I wouldn't like get mad,
but he'd like give me shit.
So like I had to tobacco inside toner.
It's just the outside.
Oh,
okay.
But it's just like,
if you don't roll it fat enough,
um,
I see what you're saying.
The tobacco leaf on the outside,
now you,
those Tibet.
What's really weird is those tobacco
leafs are the debts,
the same leafs.
It's on cigars,
but you don't inhale cigars,
but you inhale this so you get so fucked
up from these things.
In a weird way,
it's a little bit of nicotine.
I mean,
I,
there's a lot it's battling.
It's like,
it's like stupidity and,
and,
and peace are battling together.
I,
um,
love weed.
Weed's my favorite.
I remember when I had to tell my mom
that your weed smoker.
Well,
she found weed in my,
uh,
in my room and then she told me,
she was like,
yeah.
She was like,
if I ever catch you smoking weed,
she was like,
I'm going to beat the shit out of you.
But then the second I turned 18,
she was just like,
and then it started to become legal.
She was like the first person to try to
get a card.
Really?
Yeah.
My mom smokes tons,
but my mom's a party areas.
Well,
why was she worried about you?
Because she,
when she was young,
she did a lot of crazy stuff.
Oh,
she was,
she was going to ruin your life.
Yeah.
She's doesn't want me to,
you know,
get crazy.
Well,
the people always resist the idea that
their children are going to become
adults,
bothers them.
And it bothers them that their children
are going to face the same tests.
You know,
when your,
when you become a parent you realize
like,
you think about all the stupid shit that
you barely survived.
Yeah.
Like God damn it.
Like what about my kids?
They're going to have to make those same
stupid mistakes and then,
you know,
people want a helicopter parent nerf the
world.
I'm good dude.
Yeah,
my Mama,
my mom loves me so much.
She just,
she can't,
I mean,
she's a mom.
She care.
She had me when she was like 19,
so when she was,
um,
she just doesn't want me to turn out to
be a beggar,
which I mean,
I think I'm not going to be yachts.
Dude.
You're a man.
You're done Zack.
He made it through,
what is this?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Play this because it's hilarious.
This is the trump something.
Then the reporter
correcting them.
Listen to us.
Is it not going through?
Hmm.
We have a little bit of a sound here.
Costs,
bring it all the way back to the
beginning of [inaudible] six electoral
college votes.
I guess it was the biggest electoral
college wind since Ronald Reagan.
You said today that you had the biggest
electoral margin
votes for Obama got 365
330 when George Hw Bush 426 when he won
as presence.
So why should Americans cross?
We'll no,
I was told I was given that information.
I don't know.
I was just given,
we had a very,
very big margin.
Why should Americans across from you
when you accused the information they
received from being vague when you're
providing information as well?
I don't know.
I was giving you that information
I was getting,
I've actually,
I've seen that information around,
but it was a very substantial victory.
Do you agree with that?
Thank you.
That's good enough.
So yes,
this is craziness.
This is crazy.
It's like you saw him adjust it mid
sentence where he was like,
ah,
I was talking about Republicans and then
it turns out this guy hit him with a
bomb.
It's almost like he verbal boxed him.
Like he set him up with that because he
had Herbert Walker in his pocket.
He built up,
you know,
he went Obama and then he hits it.
He is Lord.
Why was I was talking about Republicans
and then he held this George Herbert
Walker Bush boom,
which was like,
what is it for 55,
he won by landslides.
Yeah.
Damn.
And then what did he do?
What trump did?
He just goes,
Eh,
yeah.
It's just weird.
That's sort of the information I was
given.
Like you want to know something funny?
When I did the roast battle,
um,
this is a great moment just for me as a
Hispanic man.
Um,
I told that Barron trump joke with,
I don't know that there was a joke.
I did and it was right after the lady
got fired from snl.
Right.
And the joke I did was,
um,
and Dan Nolan was the one who wrote it
and he kept,
he pushed me so hard to do it and I was
like,
I don't know if I can do it.
He's like,
no man,
you have to do this one.
And it was like,
fine.
Um,
but he,
it was a,
and it could pass for a trump.
She's got the body of Millennia,
the brains of Ivanka and her womb is
barren.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Just a puts a play on words,
you know what I mean?
It's hilarious.
So,
and it was just a good show mean eh,
she's not baron and his amazing woman.
Um,
but it was,
it was just so funny cause it was like
the next day a conservative website
wrote an article about it and the
article was about how good the joke was
because they were like,
this is how you don't write a joke or
this is swinging down against the
president's son.
This is a great joke on plan where it's,
and this can get you to win.
And it was just so funny to see people
look at that and be like,
oh,
okay.
That's just a good joke.
It was really weird that intelligent
people thought it was okay to attack his
kid.
You should.
I
mean,
you should never just attack a person,
especially a kid who doesn't mean we
here.
It's weird that people make these,
I,
they just have these decisions.
They make like that.
Yeah.
It's okay because he's a kid of the
enemy or something.
No,
it's just a little kid.
You got to hold yourself to a higher
standard.
That's why I was like making that joke.
I felt like it was,
it was a higher standard,
but the good that you have that higher
standard because I think we all
recognize that the base idea,
that base instinct to tax someone's kid
like that.
Yeah.
The best part though was,
uh,
after that,
someone came up to me and they were just
like,
we don't want you to not make jokes.
We just want you,
if you could please,
you know,
not mention Barron trump anymore,
that'd be great.
Yeah.
No,
it was like,
don't make a habit of it.
I was like,
no,
I mean,
I'm not gonna,
but I was like,
thanks.
I was like,
oh,
that's feels cool that they told me to
not do something.
And I was like,
oh,
that's great dude.
You're a rebel.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's,
it's a really good joke.
As you said,
it's a play on words.
It's not mean at all.
It's not meet at all,
nor is it really a joke about him.
It's just his name.
It's a great joke.
That's really pretty flawless joke when
it comes to that subject,
you know?
Right on the line.
Some people would just say,
you're crossed it,
but I think that they're wrong.
And I think that's a perfect point
because it's like you have to not make
these jokes to fine line,
but it's like as Comedians,
that's our job,
right?
We got it.
Not push the boundaries and like say
terrible things,
but it's like you see a challenge,
you know?
See how finely you can walk that line
when you see a guy like trump going
through this,
whatever he's going through right now.
Do you think that that's just the,
this is just total speculation.
Do you think that's the weight of all
these people that are upset at him?
Do you think that's the magnitude of the
job?
Do you think he,
this is just who he is.
I don't know if this is who he is.
Um,
I think he definitely,
I think from what we can see is he
definitely stepped into a job he thought
he could do.
And now he's just like,
oh,
okay.
Cause there's definitely some times
where you watch them and you see him try
to run it like a business or the way he
talks to people.
Whereas just like,
oh,
that's the way a boss would talk to
someone that he thinks is employed by
him.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
I think he's also going through the
scrutiny of some of the smartest people
in the world,
man.
And I don't think he ever has been
through that.
And I think he's gone through the
scrutiny of the general public in an
entertainment sense.
And then as sort of a,
you know,
a cultural icon census is the term of
this billionaire,
flamboyant character puts his name on
all of these fabulous buildings and runs
casinos and all that stuff.
I mean,
that's how we thought of him.
He's like a bad ironman.
Well,
he's,
you know,
he's Donald Trump.
I mean,
he's,
you don't get to be that successful
without some crazy drive to win.
And sometimes you know,
you,
you get this blinders sorta almost bull
headed determination forward and guys
like that conquered worlds.
Yeah.
You know,
that's the real deal,
man.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
That mindset that it's not always
correct,
but it's somehow or another almost
always prosperous.
Yes.
And they can get through,
they can get through,
but I think the guy like that who's so
business savvy and so it was good at
making money and some would argue,
maybe you're right,
maybe I'm wrong.
You know,
that he just invested his dad's money.
I've heard all that,
but he still made a lot of fucking
money.
Right.
Maybe,
you know,
who knows how much,
I don't know how much money you made and
he's gotten money that's for switches.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And I feel like all throughout history,
those guys that have done that have been
like conquerors.
Yeah.
This is just,
he's just getting to do it in business.
You know?
Now he's trying to do it on a global
scale,
but I think that that's almost like the
mindset of those like super billionaire.
I mean,
they have like conquerors genetics or
something.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
He's got like a little bit of Alexander
and yeah,
but I think there's just humans like
that.
Yeah.
But now those humans find themselves in
business like these like super winner
characters,
you know,
fuck what you care about.
Fuck what you think.
You know this,
we're going to do it my way.
You know?
Sometimes I feel like I have that drive
to,
you know what I mean?
Where it's like now,
especially where it's like,
I,
I get that.
You know what I mean?
Like that driver,
it's like,
fuck it and let's just work hard and get
the shit done.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't know if that's what he's got.
I mean,
it definitely think he's got some of
that.
Yeah.
I mean it's definitely misplaced in a
nod direction.
Well,
it's just under the scrutiny of all of
these insanely intelligent people now.
It's just really,
really fascinating.
Like that reporter like that,
that kind of interaction is a new thing
to him.
Oh yeah.
It's the,
just the way he communicates.
It's,
I don't think he's ever been in a
situation where I think he's always been
in a situation where he definitely feels
and thinks,
he's like,
I'm definitely the smartest person in
the room right now.
But like when you put up up against
someone that are,
you know,
more intelligent and like also have
their shit ready in their facts,
he,
he doesn't know how to like handle that
and then he just like breaks down in a
sense what you just saw,
you know,
he like change his words and he like,
uh,
it's really interesting from a
psychological perspective,
you know,
Howard stern had a really fascinating
take on it and his take on it was that
trump really wants to be loved and
that's a bad job for him because of
that.
Oh yeah.
Because there's a precedent.
There's no president that's ever been
universally loved,
I feel,
you know what I mean?
I have way more like,
either people love you or people hate
you.
Yeah.
It's one of the other,
it doesn't say,
it's never like,
oh I can live with them.
Yeah.
You know,
like some people were like,
I could live with them.
With George W after nine 11 his approval
rating went through the roof.
I remember that.
Yeah,
I do because he made us feel better.
He did,
you know,
like we said,
okay,
well when some shit goes down this is
the kind of guy you want there.
Some guy who gives a real good speech
right afterwards has this strong
military backing and going,
okay,
this is what we need right now.
Yeah.
And
a lot of ways you know that that was
what you need after some sort of a,
a global crisis like that you need some
and a leader.
Yeah.
So that was probably like the one time
that I can remember just,
and it wasn't that long before people
giving up on him again,
you know,
after mission accomplished maybe.
I heard that that was like the beginning
of the end.
Once they did that,
they had that they had a warship with a
giant mission accomplished banner in the
background and the war is,
you know,
goes on for another like seven years.
Right.
So why did the war end there?
How much later after that mission
accomplished at the war actually end my
favorite.
Yeah.
There was a dude whose job it was to go
get that printed up.
Oh my God.
He probably would just staring at it
like
so insanely.
Someone talked to him and they said,
sir,
it's over.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Perfect.
Put up the flag.
Let's do this.
Put up the banner.
Yeah,
look at that mission accomplished.
Dad.
Seems like a scene in a movie,
doesn't it?
And when you look at that photo,
it's like,
is that real?
Is that really what happened?
Folks?
As you get older and you see this thing
going on,
you see these people and you see the
presidents and you see the White House
and Congress and you realize after
Awhile,
oh,
these are all just people.
Yeah.
These are all just people,
human beings,
and they are entrapped in this system
that they've constructed.
In order to dictate where they go,
when they go,
how much they get and how they can live.
I mean that's really what it is,
is a series of laws that the,
the,
the Jack,
the general idea is they're there to
protect you and your interest,
but in a lot of ways,
not really.
No,
we don't trust it.
It's just a system.
Yeah.
Oh,
system of control that we all agree to.
Yeah.
Man.
You know,
I think that it's so funny cause it's
like the more stuff that happens with
him and then just seeing everything,
the more and more,
I'm just like,
this isn't real.
This is all just,
this has to be a joke.
Yeah.
It feels,
it doesn't feel real,
but it never did.
It feels less and less real.
What time though?
It does you,
I mean you always make this joke where
we're like,
we're in a simulation and there's many a
day where I'll just specially going on
the road with you just being here just
anywhere.
I'm just like,
Oh,
if this was a simulation,
this is definitely the simulation I'd be
playing.
Yeah.
It seems like this is a fun one to play.
It seems like there's a lot of game
elements in it.
It seems like there's good decisions,
bad decisions,
and the repercussions for each.
It's insane.
Yeah.
It's a weird,
weird world that you live in.
When a popular person wins the
popularity contest for the first time,
know like someone who decides that they,
they're going to run things like there's
never been a guy like trump who's run a
country like that and we just became
like a really popular person and then
just took over the country.
Fascinating.
Absolutely insane.
My favorite,
just the people that fall
that's like,
I can't,
I love just watching them and talking to
them.
Some people are happy that there's
chaos,
no mistake about that.
There's some people that are happy that
he's in there because they think that
the system that was in place was
insanely corrupt and I think they're
right.
They're banking on him being the
solution to that,
you know?
Because of his business savvy.
I don't understand politics or finances
enough to know if they're right.
I don't.
Yeah,
but I know that like culturally it's
weird.
The whole thing is weird.
I feel like,
you know the difference between right
and wrong.
Yeah.
I would hope so.
I,
you know,
it's not even,
it's not necessary.
I think it's an impossible job.
Oh yeah.
I really do.
I think it's,
it's,
I think we should phase it out.
I think we should figure out how to get
a large group of people,
you know?
And I think
you can go as many as like a dozen and
have these people work it out like
really smart people.
Yeah.
All scientists now.
Different,
different disciplines.
I think you'd have to have people from
the medical profession who'd have to
have people from the scientific
communities,
biology,
um,
astrophysics.
You'd have to have people that are
predicting like what's going on with
asteroids.
We cool.
Is Everything cool or should we just,
should we just fuck it,
do whatever we want?
Because we're going to get hit by a
giant rock 40 miles wide,
you know,
in 10 years.
So we just chill.
I do,
yeah.
I need people smarter than me to fucking
decide stuff.
Like that.
Cause it's one of the things where it's
like,
like I'm an idiot,
but I'm also pretty kind of well versed
on a lot of things.
Yeah.
But I mean I don't know anything about
finances.
I mean I like to think I know a little
bit about politics,
but I mean if there's a group of
scientists and people that are really,
you know,
design,
I'd much rather have that.
And then one dude,
he's not a big fan of a certain round
people.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm exactly like that.
I don't know shit about politics,
but I do know and I talk about it and
people,
we shouldn't talk about swim.
You don't shoot.
I'm not,
I'm not even going to study that crazy
system.
I think it's ridiculous.
I think you can kiss my ass.
People allowed to give you money and
then you do things that they want you to
do that donate money to you and then you
make decisions that benefit them and
what we're for real.
Yeah.
I don't need to be smart to know that.
That seems a little bit fucking weird.
That systems crazy.
It's just old as fuck.
And that's how they had to do it in the
17 hundreds okay,
thanks.
It's 2017 we could come up with a better
system.
This,
yeah.
Across the board.
You know,
like everyone's tripping about the
immigration,
which they're deporting illegals and
stuff.
They really are,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's so is it more than they used to
deport people cause how much of the used
to deport you still deporting regular
amounts of people.
From what I understand from what I've
looked at,
but the thing that I'm worried about and
that worries me is that it's like
there's certain people that obviously
are illegal here and are getting sent
back.
Not all of them,
but just the fact that there's some that
are getting sent back that are American
concerns me.
Yeah.
And there's that are really cool as
fuck.
Cause I mean I haven't really nice,
beautiful,
real fucking cool as fuck.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a lot of really nice people.
Yeah.
I make this joke now where it's like I,
I joke about losing my id and how that's
going to be a big problem for me now.
It's like if I get stopped and then I
have to convince this dude that I'm
American,
you know what I mean?
A lot of people that hear me say that
jug or like,
oh,
that's not real.
That's steel.
Well that's dumb fear.
It's like you can just talk to them and
it's like,
yeah,
maybe,
but what if that guy's having a fucking
bad day and also don't you think like
every other Mexican that gets cotton
that is going to be trying to give the
exact same speech.
I am 100% man.
It's just,
it's weird because they're really only
targeting Mexicans around California.
You're not going to deport Canadians.
Hot Blonde,
pan's hot blonde girl from Vancouver and
sent her home.
Yeah,
the fuck out of here.
Exactly.
Targeting Mexicans.
Right.
I would assume white people going crazy
right now.
It is my favorite limousine liberal.
My favorite too is that it's like,
you know,
I talk about these things and stuff in a
very joking manner,
but these are real problems certain
people are having.
And I went to a small show and it was in
a house and it was just a lot of like
white checks,
white guys,
which is fine.
You know what I mean?
But I could just see some of them start
to get uncomfortable with the things I
was saying,
but it's like,
you know what?
That's fine.
A wall.
I just feel like one day that's not
going to be real.
The Wall.
No,
I don't think the wall is going to be
real.
No,
I don't think that.
I don't think there's going to be,
I don't think this is a great idea.
Like a new world order.
Yeah.
You know,
like idea,
like one government to rule the world.
Yeah.
But I think it would be really nice if
people could go wherever the fuck they
want.
I just feel like this idea that you can
like legally restrict people's movement
based on patches of dearth they were
shit out onto is pretty ridiculous.
It just seems like that's going to go
away.
And if it doesn't go away a hundred
years from now,
it's going to go away a thousand years
from now.
It's preposterous.
It's like
what's the point?
People,
I mean,
whenever I talk to people what the
immigration thing,
people always,
uh,
and I respect people's opinions.
I'll listen and I'm willing to learn and
like I'll listen where you'd have to say
and if it's terrible,
I'll probably make fun of you a little
bit.
That's just how I deal with things.
Um,
but it's like California used to be a
part of Mexico.
Yeah.
If you look at the history,
but we buy it.
No,
it should say we throw myself into white
people even though my parents were all
immigrants.
We're all immigrants.
The colonocytes.
Yeah.
But it was,
um,
I mean that's why I need though people
do do that.
Like I said,
you know,
we,
I would say we,
okay,
well we killed all the Indians now and
have a bitch did zero direct connection
to me and ending Indian deaths.
But you know,
they'll say,
we did it.
You know,
when we came here,
we pushed out the native Americans,
so wait,
what is this?
And it's funny that they say pushed out,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
no,
it was pushed out in a very nice term.
So what we did to them,
I said,
tell,
yeah,
it's,
but it's that we thing it's supernatural
do.
It's super easy to get locked up into
little tribes.
We just got to give it up.
Yeah.
We got to give it up.
It's stupid.
It is old and dumb.
It's so dumb.
It's fine for teams.
Yes.
You want to play sports.
It's awesome.
Cleveland's going to tell you going to
the loo,
going to fork and go to a
representative.
We need a big asteroid that's fucking
unify everybody.
It would do that.
It definitely would.
I saw what nine 11 did to New Yorkers.
I guarantee you if we had some sort of a
mega disaster,
the people that survive who'd be nicer
to each other and they would realize how
fortunate we are.
We've just,
we've been in a time of peace for so
long that we,
we can't intellectualize like we can't
like in a conscious sense,
wrap our head around the fact that at
any moment there could be a 45,000 mile
an hour chunk of rock that slams into
us.
Yeah.
Well it can happen at any time.
We all think we're invincible.
Dude.
Those are scary.
Like there's supposed to be like 900,000
near Earth objects between us and and
Jupiter.
Oh yeah.
It's crazy,
isn't it?
Is that right?
Did you see?
There's a hope.
I'm wrong about that,
but it's something scary like that at
some insane number.
Tyson put up a diagram of the earth and
just the soldiers.
Tyson,
I think you should be real clear.
I mean,
that's the only Tyson I know.
Nah,
I'm just kidding.
Just start coding.
I'm sorry.
What did,
what did he put up?
He posted,
it was on his instagram.
It was just a diagram of the solar
system like rotating,
but then it showed like,
cause we're technically flying through
the universe and then it shows just like
it's just a group of us just all and the
moment that I realized that we're not
stationary and that we're actually just
moving through the universe,
my had fucking exploded.
Oh,
it's crazy.
Yeah,
that,
that graphic is beautiful.
It's you realize like it's taking a long
time for it to make that motion.
You're looking at over millions and
billions of years,
but that is what it's doing.
Yeah.
This is,
our world is spinning around a giant
nuclear explosion that's hurling towards
something.
What it looks like is if someone
launched some sort of a nuclear bullet
and we're looking at it in slow motion.
It's crazy.
Like have a gun launched a son bullet.
I mean that's what we're looking at.
It's just our version of time is so,
so brief that we can't appreciate that
this thing is in motion because it's
motion requires billions of years to
complete.
So it's literally like a,
a bullet getting shot through the Canon
and all those things around it are
particles that are sort of connected to
it,
like little fragments of it as it hurls
through infinity.
We're just,
we're just a speck in the history.
As I said,
I remember I was in class and they did.
It was like in the,
in time of
history or in the time it was in the
time of the universe.
Humanity is just a second.
Yeah.
It's not even that.
It's nothing.
We're just a little tiny thing.
How many more near Earth objects?
Okay.
15,629 near Earth objects have been
discovered.
Some 876 of those are asteroids with a
diameter of approximately one kilometer.
Oh or larger.
1700 God,
potentially hazardous.
1,785 of these near Earth objects have
been classified as potentially hazardous
asteroids or p h a s Jesus Christ.
You know,
when they have just three letters,
it's serious.
They broke it down.
Potentially hazardous asteroids.
1,780
I was thinking of last just last night.
I think I was talking to my friend.
What if one doesn't hit earth but
crashes into the moon and just fine?
Oh,
no bad.
It's all bad.
There's still people who think of the
moon's a hologram.
It's definitely not real.
There was one that slammed into Jupiter
that the explosion it created.
It was so big.
It was,
I believe it was like almost the size of
the earth itself.
Oh my God.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Well,
Jupiter apparently is the reason why we
are alive because Jupiter is so massive
that it draws everything.
It's like our protector.
It's like our guard dog.
Hmm.
Look at this.
Look at the fucking impact.
Watch this impact it is the craziest
shit.
Look at that.
Boom.
That's an asteroid will impact on
Jupiter.
It was the size of the earth.
It was the size of birth.
Yeah.
What the fuck man?
Why in the fuck?
The size of the whole earth
and the size of everything on this
planet.
Get the fuck out of here.
That's so insane.
That's one of those moments that you
can't even like if that happened here on
earth,
he couldn't run from it.
That's just one of those moms where you
look at it and you're like,
this is going to happen.
Well,
you know,
that's what they say earth is that earth
is earth too,
and that there was an earth one and
earth one got hit by another planet and
that's what created the moon.
Yeah.
That's like,
I think that's the most current theory
of how the the earth and the moon were
formed to weather so close to each
other.
Yeah.
There's a great diagram of an asteroid
hitting the earth.
One is what they described as exempt and
then it just shows like how it would
spin off and just a piece of it just,
and so there's a good diagram of how
that's a pretty great theory.
Now Does the moon the,
it's interesting that the moon doesn't
spin the way the earth spins,
right?
It has a different spin.
It spins around us,
but it does it spin on its axis as well.
Yeah.
Is that a stupid question?
Probably.
Right.
I just don't understand gravity,
so I should probably shut the fuck up.
The mood orbits Earth every once every
27.3 to two days.
It takes probably approximately 27 days.
So the moon moon to rotate on its axis
as a result of moon does not seem to be
spinning,
but appears to observe us from the earth
to be almost perfectly still.
Scientists call this synchronous
rotation.
Ah,
fascinating.
Wow,
that's fucking cool.
Oh,
so we're both spinning up,
dude.
It's just the way we spin and the way
it's bins appears to us that it's not
spinning.
It's amazing through the moon is up
fucking crazy thing.
There's something one quarter the size
of us,
it's dead as fuck and it's just floating
in the sky.
It's like having a dead body next to
your house that you never talk about,
but you just look at it can't die.
He's look at it on your way to school.
There's some dude who's got a skeleton
out of bench and just sitting there.
That's what we could be.
We could easily be that stupid fucking
moon floating in the universe would not
give a shit.
Now yours doesn't care.
The universe does not give a fuck if
there's water in Arizona.
He doesn't care.
My favorite,
just seeing the moon during the day and
you're just like,
oh wow,
that's trippy,
but really fucking cool.
It is so important how people smarter
than us out there.
So we could find this out.
Imagine if you and I had to figure out
what was going on.
Oh,
we'd be fucking dumb.
We'd be done.
We'd just be making fun of stuff here.
They're showing how it works here.
How has his own spins.
Every part of it is essentially the same
part.
That's kind of fascinating.
So the way the earth spins,
the way the moon spins it,
it rotates at such a synchronous order.
It looks like it's not spinning.
That's beautiful.
See,
science is just such a fucking
incredible thing that someone could
figure that out and they can tell you
and then you don't have to figure it out
on your own.
Not like,
cause that's dish.
Too much work involved.
Oh,
imagine if you had to figure out,
you know,
what is nuclear physics,
what is,
um,
what's an atom?
What's it on your own?
No,
it's the weirdest thing about people is
that we all act collectively whether we
know it or not.
We all act collectively.
And without that,
I feel like I have a booger on my nose
door.
Now you get,
why is that so embarrassing?
Because everybody has boogers,
right?
If you'd have a booger,
something's probably wrong with your
nose,
but to have one to talk about it goes
back to like childhood.
Yeah.
Like,
you know,
you catch a kid's picking their nose.
Hey,
get out of there.
Stop digging in there.
It's just that good feeling.
It's very embarrassing.
Good feeling of picking out a bugger.
Ah,
it's so satisfying,
dude.
Ever watched someone do it in traffic?
I have.
Fast forward was looking.
You're just going at it.
I had my nose fixed.
They had a deviated septum.
And uh,
after I,
uh,
after I had my nose fixed,
I was blowing out the most disgusting
blood book because it was all like scabs
and Khaled.
And I would blow it out and it would be
giant giant,
like the size of a thumb.
Jesus.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
I showed it to Thompson girl once we
were at the airport
and I blew my nose into a tissue.
I go,
dude,
you got to look at this.
And he looked,
they dry.
He's like,
he appreciated it though.
Right.
And that he really had a hard time
looking at it.
That's my favorite is just gross in hack
your friends.
Yeah.
Well that's one thing that fear factor
killed dead and me.
Oh,
gross.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one of 'em.
Right.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That came out of my nose,
son.
Jesus.
Yeah.
That was real.
I feel like you get name it.
It was giant.
I was like,
that doesn't even make sense.
Um,
I know I'm disgusting.
I showed you a booger,
but some more blood than it is a bugger.
I used to surf and a,
I was bad at it,
so I would get knocked underwater all
the time.
Oh No.
Remember the first time I ever went,
I didn't realize it.
There's like when you were constantly
surfing,
you get water shoved up your nose all
the time.
So like there's just a moment where
you'll be out doing something and it'll
all just release because the pressure's
gone.
So remember I was like,
I don't know if it was like talking to
my girlfriend or something,
but I was just talking to someone and
then just all of a sudden just released
and I'm just talking to them and just
salt water all over my face.
Whoa.
Just discussing that is discussed
dude.
Asteroids freaking me the fuck out.
Right.
We shouldn't have brought that up.
That's it.
That's one thing that could just change
everything.
Yeah.
And they happen all the time.
Like we just missed one.
One.
One came between us and the moon didn't,
it wasn't the one that recently came
between us and the moon and he trumps
going to build a wall or it's about to
see if,
see if you could find out what the hell
is.
By the way,
let's go champ.
Everyone calls me that now what I want,
Champ champion.
Such a great feeling.
It's to like,
I've got to open mikes and split champ
champ.
It was like,
God,
it feels good.
Do you know who Shannon Cannon Briggs
is?
The names hilarious instagram.
I had him on the podcast.
Steel chimp.
Yeah.
This,
that Sam.
Let's go champ.
That's where,
that's where the hat comes from.
This is an authentic,
let's go champ hat from the source.
Oh my God.
That's the best.
I felt it appropriate to where you are
now.
The roast battle champ.
What happened?
January 9th January 9th Jesus Christ.
It was last month.
People.
That's insane.
Oh,
that's what scary.
We're in a goddamn shooting zone.
We're going to look a shooting gallery.
Isn't that what a Randall Carlson was
saying?
Is that how he described it?
We really are these right?
There's a bunch of shit out there that's
a 1,700 and something or enough or they
could kill us.
Asteroid came within the half the
distance from Earth to the moon flying
through cis lunar space.
What is CIS lunar?
Is that like the sex it was born with?
Yeah,
cause that's his gender to cis lunar.
Is that connected to see fucking idiot
dude.
He was a new with is Sir prefixes.
What is the sis?
What is the SIS prefix?
What does that really
mean?
There's someone online right now just
screaming at us.
You fucking idiot.
She didn't talk about space sis lunar
space this morning.
Scientists at the Catalina Sky Survey
discovered the asteroid,
which is being called Asteroid Two oh
one seven age 13 on Saturday.
Discovered it on Saturday.
Jeez.
They discovered it on Saturday.
Is that what they're saying?
I think so,
yeah.
Oh my God.
50 to 111 feet across was moving at
about 10 miles per second.
Oh,
mine.
Miles per second with the same size as
the asteroid that hit Russia in 2013 the
size,
the asteroid coupled with how fast it
was moving and how low it's Albedo
brightness made it difficult to view
through a telescope that's fast,
that is,
see it's dark and they can't see it.
It's so fast.
I didn't see it.
Oh,
that's insane to me.
Would you rather be on the east?
The fuck out of me,
man.
Which steps be on the asteroid or on the
earth.
You want to be right under where it
hits.
You don't want her to survive.
You don't want to be eating people.
You don't.
You just don't want that to go down.
You don't want to get to that spot.
Are you eating people?
Cause that's where it goes it where it's
where it goes.
When it gets down to almost everyone's
dead and there's almost no life and
there's almost no food and there's just
all you need is one or two aggressive,
mean assholes.
And next thing you know,
you justify some shit and you're an an
on an episode of the walking dead
asteroid,
buzzed Earth and Moon January 25th what
does it,
another one's a different one.
Oh Jesus fucking Christ.
You're going to terrify joe today.
This is the January 25th one so the
other one was January of [inaudible] six
is that what it was?
Seventh seventh or eighth I think.
Oh my God,
we're tripping about walls,
man.
We ain't tripping out to plug in the
asteroids.
Oh my God.
I found this one on the 20th,
she pass between Earth and the moon.
Late Tuesday night,
according to the clocks and the
Americas,
the asteroid closest approach was 1145
eastern time on January 24th,
2017 Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
Came within.
I don't know what that means.
Zero Point six eight lunar distances.
Whoops.
God Damn Popup Windows,
um,
0.68 lunar distances about 61602000200
52 miles.
Slu broadcast a show about this asteroid
last night,
which you can see in the video above.
And what website is this?
Uh,
Earth's chi.org.
But most of this information is keeps
coming from Slu,
which is an observatory.
Oh,
thank God.
Those guys are watching to see death
coming with not a goddamn thing we could
do about it of they tell us.
Do you think they,
if,
if an asteroid is going to hit her,
do you think they tell trump?
No,
I don't know what you do.
What do you do if you know everybody's
dead?
Yeah.
Do you think?
He tells us like if they're,
if you're not even,
it doesn't have to be trump,
but you think if you're the president
and you find out the world's going to
end because of an asteroid.
Do you tell everybody,
well,
no one wants to feel completely
helpless.
Yeah,
but we absolutely are.
We've been hit by planets.
You fucks.
We could get hit by a goddamn planet.
Well,
I don't know if you guys know this,
but they think there's another fucking
planet at the end of our solar system.
Now.
They don't know where it is,
but they think it's six times bigger
than the earth.
I've actually heard that there's can't
see it because of the shadow steak.
It's crazy.
This university's crazy.
There's rogue planets,
rogue planets go flying around and
slamming other planets like billiard
balls.
Then they find a planet that like live
they think is literally just a diamond
dude.
I was,
I was high as fuck once and I went
outside and it was foggy and the moon
was full and it was foggy and so it was
this crazy illusion like there was a
enormous moon flying in the sky.
Oh,
enormous moon.
Like many,
many times larger than the moon itself.
Like it was almost like another planet,
like she's hovering right over us
because of the glow of the moon.
And I remember looking at that man and
thinking to myself that could,
that could be another reality.
There could be another planet somewhere
out there in the universe that is
looking up at this gigantic thing that's
like a up another planet,
just floating row right above you.
And there's,
they're everywhere.
They're everywhere.
They keep finding new ones,
which are just flying through this shit
storm of planets in nuclear explosions.
Fuck man,
that's crazier than anything that we,
we ever contemplate on this earth while
we're alive.
Just the very nature of space itself.
There's a,
I think there's a diagram of like the
biggest son,
the other biggest star they found in the
universe and then they compare it to
ours.
Current son.
That's insane.
And it's just,
it's unfathomably big.
It's insane.
One of the cool,
uh,
I guess it's a demo.
It's an,
it's an application on the vr thing I've
got on the HTC vive.
You can go into space and,
uh,
like generate planets and send them into
orbit and you're just standing in the
middle of it and you can make that Alec
Alpha Centauri Star and then watch what
it looks like when you send the earth
around it and then they explode into
each other and you can,
you can just keep making them pop up and
what have you.
Just stand there for hours.
It looks,
it's super cool.
Okay.
Wow.
Damn University.
My girlfriend's super into science and
conspiracy things and stuff.
So this is literally all we talk about.
Well,
I think that you're going to get to a
point where virtual reality is going to
be able to recreate a journey through
space.
I can age d oh you know,
if they can,
if they can figure out a way to take
really good photos,
like some of the more recent photos
they've been able to take with those
satellites that they launch into space,
they're the incredible detail of all
these different planets.
I mean to be able to do that,
like to put on one of those htc vives
and the fly through space insane and
just feel what it would be like to
circled Jupiter and like look at it.
You know,
that's all you get lost in for.
Oh,
I would love to do just weed and
mushrooms on that.
That'd be crazy.
He might not even need it,
dude.
That's true.
Might go into a natural psychedelic
state if you could.
If you could get something or you could
in a float tank,
put on an htc vive and go for real.
Right.
And Go flying through like the rings of
Saturn and to be like that close and,
and to,
to have like the correct.
Whoa.
Watch this incredible moment.
An Indian rocket releases over 100
satellites into space in a new world
record.
What,
see,
that's another thing.
Oh,
space junk.
Correct.
The aid of a merchant are going to try
to take a picture of earth every single
day.
Oh my God.
It seems like they're trying to do
exactly almost what you were trying to
talk about right there.
Um,
did you see this?
There was a,
some sort of a,
um,
a plan to collect space junk that
failed.
Did you hear about that?
That is nearby.
Oh yes.
Stays Japanese.
What is a Japanese,
uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Space junks insane.
That's what I,
that's where the part we're,
we're,
we're at,
this is where we got to build something
to go collect all the space junk.
Yeah,
we're crazy.
We left shit floating in the sky above
our head.
We've got metal.
We left metal in the sky above our head.
Oh,
it failed.
It's great.
The Japanese space junk remover
experiment has failed in orbit.
Would,
uh,
what happened to it?
Is it saying,
wait,
does that mean that there's more junk
now in space?
I don't know if that,
I don't know if they made it back and
couldn't catch it.
The system designed by a Japanese space
agency and a fishing net company should
have unfurled a 700 meter a tether from
space station risks resupply vehicle
that was returning to earth according to
j a x a scientist.
However,
the system appears to have faltered.
Space junk is a growing problem in low
earth orbit since the beginning of the
space.
Age Debris as small as flecks of paint.
Wow.
Enlarge as whole satellites and parts of
rocket boosters have been accumulating
and is estimated that over 100 million
individual pieces of junk.
Wow.
Tens of thousands of peep pieces that
are over 10 centimeters in size are
whizzing around our planet.
That's like moving shrapnel.
Oh my God,
we're so crazy.
It's insane.
People are so bananas.
They just keep launching new shit up
there.
They're like,
well,
it's fucked already.
Let's launch a hundred more new ones.
Didn't Elan Musk said they want to
launch a certain,
like a crazy number of a space,
one a month or one a.
What?
Are they leaving debris in space too?
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
Is that bringing the thing back?
So maybe not.
Yeah.
Right.
If you can get something that you can
shoot up there and then bring back,
what do you go to space.
If you good puck,
Yo,
you wouldn't even just,
I mean if it was just like top and then
come right back down.
A whole joke about that.
I go look up.
You're already in space going out there.
It's like just go into a Shittier
neighborhood.
Yeah.
You want to check out the shit and
neighborhood?
No,
you're getting planes all the time.
What if it just went a little higher?
Yeah,
exactly will.
It doesn't.
That's why I get in place.
I think that's what's,
fuck.
I think there's going to get to a point
where the planes are going to get to
places faster.
They're gonna use the orbit and go up
high and then come right back down.
Or you smoke a joint.
Go to Joshua tree and lay on your back
and realize you are already in space.
You're already here.
We're in space.
We're just in the best possible
neighborhood.
Let's just be thankful.
Just be super lucky that we're here.
We,
we weren't shit out on the moon where
there's no air.
That's true.
Yeah,
man.
I mean you like extreme stuff.
You wouldn't,
might want to just see what it was like,
fuck you.
I don't like things that will definitely
kill you.
Oh,
okay.
And the like going into space can
definitely kill you.
Oh,
absolutely.
Like,
yeah,
it goes wrong.
A lie.
It goes wrong a lot on those folks.
Like I'm terrified of heights,
so I'll probably never go,
but that movie gravity.
Oh yeah.
Don't be freaked me the fuck out.
That's sitting there going,
Jesus,
get back down there,
get down,
get down.
Her anxieties.
So real.
It's part of it.
The fuck out of there.
You're floating in space.
You hear the things crashed together,
but they don't make any sound or you see
them crash together,
but there's no sound.
That was a freaky part of that movie
where there's no sound in space because
there's no oxygen.
There's no air,
there's nothing to carry it.
There's nothing.
It's no APP.
That's fair.
You don't hear it.
Does that make sense though?
Yeah.
Just real quick on that.
The asked for the hit Jupiter,
it wasn't the size of earth.
The explosion was the size of earth,
however difference that makes.
But the explosion was the side of the
road.
Yeah,
I think we said that.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm just making sure.
Yeah.
I don't think the astro was decided if
it was a big dog,
be like another planet flying around.
Right.
Well,
that has happened though.
That's what we're saying.
I don't know.
I mean who knows how often does it
happen,
but they think that's how what were
saying before the debts,
see if he could find that earth one in
earth too.
I think that's what they're saying,
that that was the most recent theory of
how the moon was created,
that the moon is actually made out of
the same shit that were made out of just
dead as fuck floating in the sky.
Our brother,
it's her dead brother floating over our
head every day,
but he's only like 10 that's why so
little.
And it's like the one that's still
attached to us,
dude.
I mean,
that is what it's like,
right?
Yeah.
That could be us.
I couldn't be as,
we're so lucky.
It's what I'm going to work hard bitch
and complain
Weird Times.
Yeah.
Because it will all this information,
like I'm sure it was probably around
when my parents were my age,
but uh,
in order to go get it,
you had to do a lot of traveling.
You had to read books.
He had a,
he had to go to school.
Like you couldn't just google it.
No,
everything's so readily available now.
Don't you think like for comics it's
like the best time ever for creating
material?
Absolutely.
That's why it's like,
I mean I talk about trump and stuff all
the time,
but it's like I've never seen a
president that's just given us so much
stuff to work with.
A comic said this to me.
Uh,
he was like,
I'm,
I'm not gonna write any trump jokes.
So I was like,
why not?
And he's like,
cause that dude's doing funnier shit
than anything I'll ever be able to
write.
I feel,
I feel bad about it.
Is it just fit?
It doesn't feel,
this is my feeling.
It doesn't feel like everybody's happy
now.
Everyone's not happy and when people
aren't happy on both sides,
like this seems to be all this fucking,
it seems super tense right now.
No,
I think we were talking about this
early.
No one's willing to listen and learn.
Everyone's just willing to shout as loud
as possible.
Yeah.
People just kind of be nice.
And that's why I like doing stand up
about it,
cause it's like if I can make both sides
laugh at this,
the stupid things I'm saying when
they're in a way agreeing with me and
then in a way can hopefully learn a
little bit different.
Yeah.
I think we're too much of a bunch of
babies to have a left side and a right
side.
I think we're too,
we're too much of babies were,
were squawking too much.
Yeah.
You know,
I think if we could figure out a way to
get rid of that,
that whole,
that whole inclination to want a left
and a right,
that whole inclination just seems to me
that it's just so easy to pick a team
and to get locked into that team's
mindset.
Locked in that team's goals locked in
that team's ideology.
Say the shit that the other people in
the team.
I see so many people that have right
their tweets now and afterwards they
write sad.
It's hilarious.
I mean,
it's kind of funny in an ironic way.
If they mean it.
Ironically.
It's funny,
but it's,
it's really funny when they don't mean
it.
Ironically,
and they were like mimicking the way
trump tweets.
Yeah,
I see it.
It's so common now.
We got sad
president of the tweets.
I know.
It's amazing.
I mean,
hope it doesn't tweet.
I know,
right?
Shit.
He don't know what the fuck they're
talking about.
That was taken out of context.
That's a bad trump impression.
He's like,
Matthew were shark should have won.
He has a,
what is this?
This is what I could find on that
giant impact creates moon the
scientist's theory on a giant impact
model seeking to explain the moon's
creation.
Experts believe that an object that
crashed into earth led to debris that
later form the moon.
New Theory says that incident also
created a smaller second moon.
Whoa,
where's that?
And it's these two minutes right here.
It says,
day they collided to create what we see
now.
Oh Jesus Christ.
It was really hard finding stuff on this
earth.
One earth to stuff really brings up just
a lot of stuff on DC.
Wow.
How would they figure it?
These
fucking people are so goddamn smart.
Look at this.
Their theory also says the slow,
the slow impact force,
most of the smaller moon to attach to
the side of the moon as a thick new
layer of the lunar cross.
How the fuck did you figure that out?
They're destined to
collide.
There's no way out.
Yeah.
You should freak out,
folks.
Everyone should freak out and then let's
relax.
Oh,
yikes.
This is what's the most important thing
to realize.
No matter what we're in space no matter
what.
No matter what you're saying.
The,
the,
the reality of what you're looking at,
what you're focusing on.
If you look close to your,
your neighborhood or your,
your,
your city or your country,
all of it is taking place in this ball
hurling through infinity ass like that
is,
it's all figurative.
We,
we've,
we're creating all of these social
constructs.
Well,
they're there.
You got to deal with them.
You mean you got to deal with the
consequences of,
you know,
assholes.
It fuck things up over here.
Yeah.
These Hitler felt fellows and when you
get a Hitler really got to do something
about it,
you know,
he's not going to get to,
you can't just hug it out of him.
No,
no,
I do you think it get some beach?
Well,
I'm not saying he's Hitler.
Oh,
of course it talking about Hitler.
Yeah.
I wasn't talking about him like,
like what people call other people that
he's like Hitler.
I never used that term and I don't think
he is like Hitler.
No,
no,
he's not because he's not killing
people.
Then also,
you know,
they Hitler's a whole total different,
no,
Hitler was Hitler.
Yeah.
Like it's solar.
It's so stupid.
I think borough had a bit about it.
He has on his new specials.
Have you seen him?
I haven't seen his,
especially special.
It's so great.
I saw him do the stand up.
I need,
I need to sit down and watch it.
And it was one of my favorites.
My favorite is watching him pop into the
store and do it.
And I watched him do that bit and it's
such a funny bit cause he's got a great
point.
Yeah,
he definitely does.
And I think it's a tired word now is,
and no one's going to bring that fucking
mustache back though.
I'll do it.
You think so?
I'll,
I'll bring it back.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Already did it once.
More it on stage.
People were so angry at him.
He's like,
I'm a Jew.
I could do it.
I would you pass.
It's so funny.
It's funny the things that we find
offensive.
Yeah.
It's a weird time for that.
Yeah,
it is.
People are getting really upset,
upset at,
um,
people talking about,
you know,
pretty much any subject that isn't about
them as an individual.
And then if you do,
like,
if you do a subject,
if you're a white man,
you should be writing entirely about
what a white man does,
period.
That's it.
Just about white men.
And even then you shouldn't be doing it
because you should shut the fuck up.
Nah,
man.
Yeah.
Now I,
I was things like you can say whatever
you can,
I believe in freedom of speech more than
anything,
but I also believe that you have to deal
with the consequences of what you say
fuck Yo.
But it's also like we have to stop
looking at each other as groups,
white man as groups,
as white women as group.
So it was taught,
it's silly.
We're just a bunch of fucking people.
We got to stop looking each other as
these groups based on what we look like
or what part of the country we're in and
that's eventually going to move to other
countries.
It's just going to take time.
I just wonder when,
you know,
cause the kind of relationship that we
have with each other all in together in
a city like this and live in so
comfortably and for the most part like
relatively low crime,
even in a place like Los Angeles,
if you really consider it that never
existed in history.
This is a new thing.
So people get better at life,
they get better at figuring it out.
I think we're better now than ever
before.
Even though we still fuck it up.
Yeah.
But we're,
we're real close to one day recognizing
other countries just like states,
just like,
you know,
like you could just pack up and move to
Florida,
you know,
there's,
there's going to be situations like that
where people just go all over the world
and go wherever they want.
Yeah.
It's going to be weird.
It's going to be,
I mean,
it's also just progress.
Someone said it's like progress is
measured generate or by tombstone.
By tombstone.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
True.
Where it's like I look at my grandfather
and like he's,
I love him to death and he was an
immigrant to this country and he felt a
certain way around about other people
and races and it was one of those things
where it's like,
I,
growing up,
growing up around that,
I realized it's like,
oh,
that's just kind of the way he thinks.
I don't have to think that way.
I can treat people nice and be cool with
everybody.
Yeah.
It's,
I think that's more apparent now than
ever before.
Yeah.
I think that some people were more aware
of,
um,
the,
the similarities that we all share
versus the differences more than ever
before and people were more vocal I
think anytime in my life that I can
remember.
I'm sure that during the civil rights
movement people were very vocal about
racial,
racial rights and,
uh,
you know,
when,
uh,
putting out of stomping out racial
hatred,
but I don't remember it being like as
much in the public forum as it is during
the last,
like say like maybe 10 years or so.
It seems like the people have,
they're much more organized in their
ability to,
uh,
to protest,
to educate people,
to explain things,
to show things that people might not
have been aware of before.
I think it's a lot of
just,
um,
social media and just the Internet and
having all that just readily more
available.
Yeah,
there's definitely that.
I think people like,
I think people arguing having these
conversations are super important.
Even if they do get shouty and stuff.
Cause that's,
I think that's how you learn is you have
to have these awkward hard
conversations.
Yeah.
And they're there.
It's really hard.
It's,
it's hard to,
uh,
it's hard to think that every time you,
you buy anything,
anytime you,
uh,
anytime you do any kind of interacting
with someone,
you're these,
a lot of the stuff that you're getting
is coming from places where people live
hard lives like really hard lives.
Like the,
and people will argue,
well,
hey,
this is what we've talked about this
recently.
They were like,
well,
hey,
you know,
that's how countries grow and prosper
and you know,
they have to start out this way and they
have this,
you know,
revolution,
industrial revolution and all these
people,
they start manufacturing things.
A status of life goes up,
the quality of life goes up.
Your living much better than they ever
lived before.
Yeah.
But they don't,
they don't live like us.
Yeah.
All right.
Is that it?
That's okay.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean,
went from mud house,
mud huts to Straw or whatever.
A better comparison while we were at
talking about those Foxconn employees as
folks that work and make i-phones well,
oh,
the jump off the roof so much.
They have,
yeah.
Those people were stuck in terrible
jobs.
Tell me that when you read a history
book a thousand years from now and they
talk about what kind of barbarians we
are at 2017 they will start to talk
about the rise of the machine.
Oh,
it was talking about the cell phone and
they would like the people covered it,
the cell phone so much that they,
they found a way to compartmentalize
their ideas about slave labor to the
point where these people work 16 hours a
day in a gigantic concrete structure
making their beloved phones and they
hated the job so much and they jumped
off the building so much.
They put nets around the building but
the people kept buying phones but,
but didn't they have enough phones are
ready?
They did.
They didn't care.
They wanted new phones,
new phones.
Hi Amar.
Jumpers for features that the saints,
isn't that what the pyramids maybe
potentially created by slave labor and
they were worshiped things for ideally
like a religion.
I think they used to think it was slave
labor.
I don't know for sure.
Yeah.
But I think they don't think that now.
Now think the most recent theory is that
they were very skilled workers because
of the food that they got.
Yeah.
They were almost like praise because of
what they could do.
Go back to the ancient Greece or ancient
Rome and they're giant,
uh,
places of worship,
their gods and whatnot.
I'm sure
you're right.
But here's the thing,
like those things were like really like
art.
I think we look at buildings a little
bit different when we think about like
someone being forced to build something.
Yeah.
We think of the person who's being
forced to build it as being like a low
paid worker.
Whereas in those environments,
that person might've been a goddamn
superstar,
like a guy who could build a marble
because coliseum,
you know guys who build,
built in those pillars bit people who
are figuring out how to stack these
gigantic stones perfectly on top of each
other and make stone pillars.
How the fuck did they figure that out?
Got The smart guy wasn't lifting it.
He was telling all the rest of the guys,
maybe yes,
but maybe they were all together.
I think more likely you had a lot of
smart people and then you had a few like
Leonardo da Vinci's who were fucking
super geniuses who had figured out a
bunch of crazy shit and was designing
things and drawing things and these,
these people were just like these rare
blips of like super power creativity
that exists all throughout history and
they propel us forward.
Yeah,
like a who?
I think it would be jobs then.
Yeah,
sure.
He's one of those kinds of guys.
Yeah.
Davinci.
I remember which artist it was,
but they had a,
they would make all these ideas and
they'd have like their understudies or
people that were almost as skilled as
them do these things and them.
Yeah.
I mean I think that's what happened with
the pyramids and stuff.
They probably had these people that are
planning,
but you also still need skilled workers
to build these.
Yeah,
I think will particularly something like
the pyramids.
There's a tremendous amount of math
involved and they're all doing this
somehow or another.
When they didn't even have steel?
No,
they supposedly had copper tools and
they figured out some way to grind these
stones so perfectly.
They just sit on top of each other.
Just completely flat level,
barely stick a card in the crease up to
stuff on the foxconn factories.
I remembered the said the reason why are
they at least that was their argument
why they weren't in America's,
because they had upwards of like 30,000
mechanical engineers and electronical
engineers at the ready.
So those would be your skilled workers
right in the store.
Slave labors underneath them,
but those are the extra people that
maybe that's why it's not happening.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Because I guess with something like that
where the demand is so high and the
quality of the standard so high,
like I phones think,
say what you want about iphones.
I've dropped this fucking stupid think
seven or eight times.
It works great.
You know,
I love this thing to death.
They can take a beating man.
It's crazy.
They can take a fucking beating.
These things are weird.
When these things take over.
I think it's going to be an apple robot
that takes,
I'm resisting that watch,
but it's looking tempting and it tells
you your heart rate.
I bought my girlfriend one and she loves
it and I just,
I don't want to be at home.
Phones are going to be great.
The new iphone is going to be cool.
They announce it soon.
God dammit stop.
They can't stop.
Get back on Yo.
What up?
Guilty.
That machine,
you know,
just people are having romances
connected to each other,
looking at each other through glass,
weather,
wearing goggles and making phones.
That's the only socialize and get to do.
Do you think we might have a bounce back
moment where it rebounds a little bit
and a Mumford and sons take over?
Not like that,
but like there might be a day where we
see like,
you know if
we can stop it,
but like we need to stop all of our jobs
from being taken.
We're fucked.
We're already this drinking out of Mason
Jars and wearing fucking suede boots.
That shit.
You just resisting the inevitable.
Sorry.
All in the woods.
You're on the porch with a fiddle with
your friends,
non ironically singing together and
perfect tune.
How dare you.
If you're not going to stop the rock,
it's headed this way,
that music by going how many thousand
feet to be figured out.
10 miles a second.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I can't even comprehend how fast that is
that it makes my whole body hurt.
Just hear it.
Just hearing that.
I just like go limp.
Like Ooh.
Oh,
I remember I was living in San Jose when
I found out.
I remember it was like really great
science teacher and he would just blow
my mind all the time and I remember
listening to him and he was talking
about how when you look at stars,
you're actually looking in the past
technically because it's been,
because the light's just hitting us.
It's taking so long to travel.
This is something that's happened a long
time ago.
Yeah.
When they look deeper and deeper into
the University of literally looking into
like a time machine.
Yeah.
So sane or my mind.
Great.
It's just hard.
It's hard for your stupid little head to
figure out what these people figured
out,
how they all had to agree on it.
Okay.
I know this is gonna sound crazy,
but what I'm thinking is when we're
looking at those stars,
we're looking back in time like that's
what I was going to say,
but I sound too crazy.
Okay.
Are we right?
Let's look at this.
Neat.
Get the pads out and start calculating,
calculating it and like,
okay,
do we,
when do we go public with us?
Um,
I think we're good.
I think
then we have discovered that the earth
is 4.7 billion years old and people just
telling us these calculations,
like we're waking up in the middle of
this trip.
It's like we are literally on a
spaceship and the spaceship is hurling
towards somewhere and in the middle of
this waking up,
we have to learn how to speak.
We have to learn how to remember to
write things down that we've already
figured out.
We have to be able to save those things,
send them down to the next people so
they don't have to figure it out on
their own.
And then the next people,
the next people that everybody worked
together.
And while this is happening,
you're waking up in the middle of a
spaceship and it's flying.
It's like a Scifi movie.
It is a Scifi movie.
I mean,
we did.
It literally is what's happening.
Think about how much information has
been lost throughout time.
Yeah,
right.
Like the pyramids.
That's a perfect example.
The Great Pyramid of Giza.
If you look at all those insane
photographs,
when they do those three days,
when they go over it,
you know,
with a,
with a drone and film it and you just
look at it,
you go this,
that is an insane accomplishment.
Like I can't imagine what it feels like
to be there in real life for wish
it wasn't such a sketchy part of the
world right now.
I would like to go over there.
I mean,
I'll be fine.
I just gotta go to the beard,
had a little bit longer and be quiet.
Dude,
you had slipped right in.
Have a nice one.
Then the little hats,
white hats with the lingerie style.
I wouldn't get back in,
but I would totally,
totally building shell whip right in
Bro.
No problem man.
Let that hair gets a little bit scraggly
or in your beard.
You're good.
Yeah man.
You know,
and just talk like you got a sore
throat.
So
that's one of the jokes that I'm doing
now that I add,
really had fun with,
which is like the idea of me getting
deported and going back to Mexico and
having just to be quiet the whole time
because he can't speak Spanish.
I can't speak Spanish and they can't
like let them know,
does that piss off some Mexicans,
some Mexican Americans that you can't
speak Spanish in San Jose did a little
bit grown up some,
well older Mexicans cause it's like they
look at me and they're just like,
Oh God,
what have we done?
You know what I mean?
Like at what cost is our freedom and our
dreams.
But it's,
it's kind of,
well,
I didn't learn because there was a
moment for my grandparents and my mom,
my dad,
where it was like,
we don't want him to,
we don't want people to know he's,
you know,
Hispanic like,
cause it was like almost looked down
upon that.
He's like,
you're speaking Spanish and bright,
you have to speak English,
Blah Blah.
But now it's the point where it's like,
it's much of a benefit to learn multiple
languages.
Well,
I would think if you're a guy who could
speak Spanish,
you could work in all sorts of different
countries and South America too.
Yeah.
You know,
we just had a serious leak,
ladies and gentlemen.
Oh,
Larry's,
it's in the ceiling.
Yeah,
we had a serious leak in our building.
It's fucking raining cats and dogs out
there.
Megan.
This building wet,
uh,
we in trouble.
Oh No,
we're,
it depends where it is.
What if it hits electricity?
You're saying,
I don't know.
Should we get the fuck Outta here?
Holy Shit.
I told you I'm not good with electricity
once a day full of,
uh,
whatever.
Well,
whatever happened,
it seems to me like water pooled up
somewhere and then,
then the least.
It sounds like it's right above us on
that.
I don't know where,
if there's electronic wires up there or
whatnot or how it could it came in or
what could probably look the drama.
Can I be a great credit just to,
it was like to die on Joe Rogan's
podcast do don't die.
Oh well this,
we can avoid this disaster again.
The Sky is letting us know probably up
until we have no control.
The future and the university is like,
you guys gotta stop talking about
asteroids because it's close.
Universities like,
listen bitch,
she got your own problems to worry.
Yeah.
Well just fucking water from the sky.
Uh,
there's all a talker.
Some Mexicans or mullah more Mexicans
are cool.
Then now when they meet me,
cause they're just like the proud.
It's a sense of pride and like a lot of
magazines.
San Jose hit me up like a lot of young
kids after I won,
like hit me,
I'm there like,
yeah,
fuck you,
San Jose,
blah blah.
And they're like,
you know,
I want to do stand up.
And they asked me for advice and you
know it's towel man.
Just do Mike's and shit.
Yeah,
no you,
you,
you're in a great position right now as
being a guy who successful and,
oh,
Jamie's going to go look.
You got your rubber gloves.
No,
I'm just going to like,
oh,
we got a serious situation here ladies
and gentlemen.
Okay.
Just read by a light.
It's not good.
[inaudible] want to shut that light off.
Can I set all the lights off?
No,
don't do that.
You don't want to talk in the dark?
Let's just see what happens.
I feel good about this.
I need to,
you know,
just a leak.
Just the water pouring down on us.
So they're evacuating parts of northern
California.
Correct.
I think that was,
I got to,
I think it was notification in case
there's road.
It's probably because we're near the,
some of the hills.
There's case to,
you're an area where your roads get me
any closer to the one slide,
where to go be,
be ready to leave in case you have to or
something.
I went down Laurel and there was a house
that fell off the side of the cliff.
That's that driving,
driving and watching,
like looking at those houses.
Just it's,
I get anxiety.
Yeah.
Just watching those houses.
They had a giant back porch and it just
broke off and slid down the side of the
hill.
I imagine just being that guy that made
so much money
that you were like,
finally I get to enjoy my porch.
It's raining.
I get to look at all the Hollywood hills
have worked so hard.
And then it's just like,
dude,
that's like a life changing disaster
when your house breaks and slides down a
hill,
that will change your fucking life.
There was a whole house that's slid down
the hill.
You hear it again,
Jamie?
Ooh.
It's coming down hard.
Hit outside.
I don't hear it.
Oh,
I heard like another,
there's a couple of drips with him.
They stop.
Um,
what were just talking about?
so big mudslide.
Oh,
a house on?
Um,
uh,
was it on Topanga?
No,
it was on,
Laurel was on Laurel coming up over
Laurel Canyon.
I don't know if you were here like four
or five years ago.
There was a house that's slid off the
side of the hill.
Wow.
And you could drive by it.
You see the house.
Like it wasn't like that much of a hill
either.
I mean,
you know,
it's decent,
but whatever was behind it was the
problem.
It like kind of pushed it forward like
the,
the ground broke loose above it and
pushed it forward and there was like a
big ass lawsuit and lasted forever.
But I would always drive by looking at
that place going,
this is,
this is supposed to happen like that.
It's like the earth.
It just shifts constantly.
Like our idea that we could just pitch a
tent forever.
That'd be fine.
It's fucking ridiculous.
Earth's crust,
not that deep.
Right.
Not deep enough for my tastes.
Exactly.
You know what I mean?
I just laugh at the bottom of it.
I think it's,
I,
I'm probably gonna say something real
stupid Ligo.
It's like seven miles deep,
but I feel like it's not that deep.
Yeah.
I don't think it's that much more than
that.
I know there was a,
this mining operation,
I'd like to find out what the exact
number is.
There was some mining operation,
um,
that,
uh,
they were doing this article about how
many miles is it Jamie?
Sorry,
what's that?
Okay.
Crust average.
Yeah,
necessarily.
Initially I had the radius,
it sits about 4,000 miles,
but that's the radius.
So it's a average is about 18 miles
under the continents,
but it's only about three miles under
the ocean.
Whoa.
That's only about three miles out of the
ocean and then lava.
That's how like Hawaii gets brought up.
God Damn.
I don't think that's deemed enough for
me.
That seems weird.
We're like,
there's a ball of live under our feet.
Jesus Christ,
yet we're just the crust over the sun.
Yeah,
man,
that's not good.
Yeah.
There was,
uh,
some article I was saying that,
that I read about a mining operation
where they were talking about how warm
it got.
As you got lower and lower,
deeper and deeper into the earth,
that you could literally feel the heat
of the fucking lava.
These assholes are drilling next to how
quick,
dude,
you hit wrong one.
Oh God.
You hit wrong.
You can't even speak yet one wrong vein.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's terrifying.
I wonder if they have that down to a
science.
Obviously they do,
but do they know exactly that?
They're never going to like drill a hole
into the lava and have it spew out
through the top like a Zit.
This gotta be mistakes had been made.
Did you imagine if that happened?
Can you imagine if these guys really
trying to get more diamonds like work
this more diamonds there?
But here's the deal.
Oh foot.
The diamonds is the center of the
fucking earth.
So don't drill two going to have to wear
space suits that won't allow you to use
your hands.
Say everything's going to be done in a
key pad.
You're going to have to ipad strapped to
you and you're going to have to program
it like this.
And they'll try to suck the last diamond
out and then they'll see the bubble of
red with that last diamond hole was,
and then that's the last thing they say
is the explosion.
As that hot lava shoots passed,
I'm like a broken fire hydrant.
She goes boom,
and right out of the surface of the
earth just sprays lava into the sky.
This for years and years,
that's probably one check was just like,
I want that time.
How big that's the diamond and killed
everybody and I need it for you to show
me about mate.
There's a person like that out there,
you know there are,
oh,
I have,
don't get mad people.
Sexual stereotypes are disgusting.
And I'm looking at diamonds,
actually not diamonds,
but an emerald dude.
Engagement rings or brutality.
Oh my God,
no.
Those goddamn things aren't even worth
anything.
Yeah,
there are definitely people buy it,
but the reason why people buy it for so
much,
it's because they've stockpile always
fucking diamonds and they control the
price.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's amazing.
It's so smart.
And we kind of give it up for the Jews,
but up strong marketing strategy when it
cut,
is it,
are they the Jews that run the diamonds?
It's not a bad thing to say.
People would say that that's racist.
I will tell you it's not racist.
If it's a positive quality,
they're awesome at business.
How is that racist?
Why was everybody so sensitive that you
can't even say something?
Jay Ingest about a person's positive
attributes.
Now when people think you're racist,
Mike,
the Jews are good about business.
What?
That's a good thing.
It's good thing to be good with
business.
You fuckhead my uncle,
when I told him I had an agent,
he was just like,
I have one piece of advice to give you.
And he was like,
he was like,
what?
He was like,
what kind of manager you have?
I was like,
oh,
he's like a,
it's what?
This company was like,
no,
I don't like what you know.
And I was like,
oh,
he's Jewish.
And he was like,
good job.
That's a good move.
And I was like,
what?
No,
no,
the business.
And that was,
yeah,
that was all he said to me and I was
like,
that's the weirdest thing.
It was so funny to me.
It's a weird thing the Jewish folks
because um,
especially like European Jews is more
Nobel prize winning new Europe,
European,
European Jews that I think anybody truly
weird.
Like there's a,
there's a pillar of,
of science or just a,
a pillar of pillars on a good word,
a collective of incredible minds that
have come out of European Jews for some
strange reason.
I feel like they're all hilarious to
European Jews.
Really?
Like name one.
No,
what are you saying?
Oh,
why?
I was just saying,
oh,
just sell.
Taught
going.
Huh?
You one of those,
keep going.
I love smoking weed.
He don't just take the high and say this
is it.
I'm good.
No,
I write it out
where you big stoner got grown up or no,
not until I was 30.
Yeah.
What would you say,
Jamie?
You're talking about diamonds.
Have you ever seen the people that dig
for like diamond dust and gold dust in
the streets in New York that like,
ah,
I don't know exactly what street it is,
but you know,
there's like that area at the diamond
area and they're all like doing
exchanges and whatnot.
When they're looking at them in their
car and whatnot.
Dust gets on their pants and little
little flecks fall off and they get into
the street,
into the dust and here's like a,
here's a video.
There's a gut and make,
it's probably more people that do it now
obviously,
but like they just dig through the dirt
and the dust and the street cracks and
whatnot,
and they can take it home and they can
find hundreds or thousands of dollars
worth of like diamond dust and gold dust
and diamond flex and I'm sure
occasionally they fuck,
they get like really lucky and find a
whole one,
but they're like,
it's just based off of that.
That's where all of it is happening on
like that one block in New York.
Yeah,
old school panning yet.
That's insane.
They're panning for gold in front of
these diamonds doors,
and that's probably not they found
there.
But yeah,
I heard about this couple of years ago.
I just thought maybe you'd heard about
it since you not there or dude,
well,
I never lived in Manhattan.
I lived in new Rochelle.
I couldn't afford to live in Manhattan.
That's amazing though.
I've always wanted to move to New York.
New York's crazy,
but when I was living there,
I was po and I couldn't afford the
parking.
You have a,
if I would've had to get a really shitty
apartment,
I had my apartment.
New Rochelle is pretty shitty too,
but I would have had to get a parking
spot.
You have to pay every month.
Whoa.
Yeah.
You can be a lot of money to like
thousands of dollars.
That's insane.
Yes.
I mean that's as high as it could go.
I wonder what like a good,
what's a good monthly rate for parking
in a parking structure in New York City?
It's pretty.
I've heard comics talk about,
it's pretty ridiculous.
So a lot of them don't keep cars because
now you can just uber anywhere you want.
Yeah.
Take cabs and go all over the city.
But back in the day,
if you wanted to live there and you
wanted to do road trips,
you had to have a place to keep your
car.
And it was like insurmountable for me.
It was just,
there's no way.
Something like Ed my in my day,
I remember it being like something like
$700 a month just to park your car.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I was like,
what?
Even then there's just so much traffic
in New York.
Yeah.
And this is back when I was making like
three 50 a week on average,
you know?
So it was ridiculous.
It's probably less than that now,
but there's different areas.
It looks like it's anywhere from 300
plus up to three 75 there's different
garages now.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So,
so you can get it as low as 300 bucks.
Find some that say two 50 what's an
expensive one?
The ones that I saw that were cheaper,
they stack you on top of each other.
I don't know if you've ever seen that.
That's really nuts.
Yeah.
Well I remember it was 700 bucks.
What do you mean stack on top of each
other?
They stick them into these machines and
the machines lift up and then another
car gets driven in.
The machine continues to lift up.
And so like you have to drive the cars
out and then bring the thing down and
drive that car out and bring the thing
down.
And,
and you might have to do that with like
three or four cars at that.
Like that.
Yo,
that's fucking crazy.
That sounds terrible.
It is so crazy that they could do that.
So this is the way they saved space and
stack cars and it actually does work.
But Jesus Christ,
how weird is that?
They have your car up.
I mean,
tell me one of these guys who works
there.
Can't fuck up one day.
Just people.
Fuck yeah,
there's gotta be an accident that's
happening.
People fuck things up.
You know,
a car is fallen off that thing and
landed on someone's head.
Oh,
for sure.
Right.
That's had to have happened.
Don't you think?
I've seen valet drivers.
Yeah.
Well maybe I was wrong about how much it
costs or maybe I had a very expensive
one near me and maybe it's because they
stack them.
They can do it for 300 bucks,
but whatever the amount was,
I don't remember what it was.
I didn't make any fucking money back
then.
So there's no way it was going to work.
Where are you serving back then?
Uh,
no.
Back then it was a,
that was my,
when I lived in new Rochelle is my,
my first attempt at living off stand up.
That was my first actual attempt where,
um,
before I'd always had day jobs and a day
job driving limos.
I had a day job delivering newspapers.
And so then I went from there to,
uh,
to New York and when I went to New York
I was just like almost making money,
doing stand up like almost almost like
some months.
Oh,
I made it this month,
next month,
fuck,
can I have any gigs?
You know,
it was like almost being able to pull it
off.
So whatever the amount for a parking and
then living in New York City.
Plus the thing about New York City is
New York's amazing and it's,
it's incredible that you can hop around
and go from club to club to club.
But it was harder at the time at least
to do long sets.
So like I wanted to do like sets that
prepare me for headlining on the road.
I want it to like keep doing that set
like even during the weekday.
So I just try to get it stronger and do
it all as a whole.
And that was really only available on
the road for a guy like me.
You know,
I feel like that's kind of where I'm at
now.
It's like I don't,
I can find this for the first month I
was ever able to pay my bills and
everything off his standup.
And that's a,
it was a great failing of the drug.
The launching pad.
Well,
I mean there's gotta be smarter about
it.
Cause I mean now that I have money,
that's all just going to rent so I can
afford to be on the road and to build
that time to where I can,
you know,
feature regularly and then make that
money.
Yeah,
man,
it's all right for you right now about
right new shit.
And I'm so excited about dose saloon
hustle,
Luton host saloon,
host saloon.
Yeah,
it's cool.
It's a really interesting time for you,
but that's gotta be that.
That's,
that's a great feeling though when you
to be for you too.
I mean that moment when you were able to
just live off,
stand up.
It was scary.
I didn't think I was going to make it.
I was bombing a lot too.
Yeah.
I was eating a lot of Dick every,
every other show,
something would go wrong.
I'd go down hard.
I mean,
and I got my girl with me.
So it's real.
It's,
it's when you girl sees you bomb,
that's rough.
Yeah,
it is.
She's seen me off rough on the ego.
But she was cool though because she has
that support system where she like,
she'll be like,
yeah,
you need to work harder.
But she knows him funny.
Yeah.
Right now it's finally paying off for
her too.
Well you can be a hard worker and not be
funny.
Oh yeah.
That,
that's,
that's a problem.
You know,
it's when the person is funny and as a
hard worker,
you know,
that's like the tea,
which you'd try to maintain,
try to maintain that balance but a lot
of time to get either or,
you know,
but that's the case with everything.
It's driven.
Hardier man.
I keep hearing that behind me.
I'm scared.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's cool.
I'll dude,
are you enjoying it?
I'm loving it,
man.
It's fun.
I've never,
I mean,
do you feel,
do you feel certain about everything?
Do you feel anxious?
Like Kinda,
how do you feel about like the future
you feel excited?
Do you feel?
I feel really excited cause I don't feel
the only reason I'd feel anxious if I
knew that I couldn't do it right now.
It's like,
for me it's like,
I think of it like this.
It's like I've worked so hard,
I've worked so many jobs,
have worked so many things to get this
opportunity.
So why would I squander it?
You know what I mean?
It's like an see if I've worked so hard
now,
why would I keep working harder?
Not the perfect attitude,
but I'm also like,
I'm not gonna be one of those guys.
It's like,
you know,
oh I'm a headliner now cause I'm not.
Yeah,
that's going to man stand up.
But you could,
you know,
like a little of that.
Like Tony has got a lot of that in him.
But it's also why Tony Hinchcliffe so
fucking funny.
You know,
he rides it out and he does it the right
way.
Tony Hinchcliffe is a funny
motherfucker.
Tony Hinge because a mentor of mine,
man,
I mean he was one of the first guys I
talked to before when I had my first
roast battle.
Well,
he's another dude that fucking Tony.
He hustles.
He's always hustling.
Yeah,
that kid works hard.
He's very impressive in that way.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He is.
And he's always writing new shit.
They always,
constantly,
there's a picture you posted of him when
I was,
remember when I was a younger and
counting,
I don't know if I'd worked here at the
time.
I think I had,
I think it was a door guy.
Uh,
and you'd post a picture of him.
It was right after you guys did a set
and then you had posted a picture of him
on the plane writing new jokes already
and you were just like,
this guy just didn't sat,
Blah Blah.
And He's already writing new jokes.
He goes,
Tony writes constantly.
I think you have have
to,
you can't commit to a laptop though.
He's got the stupid set up.
Whereas an ipad and it's a little fake
keyboard.
Oh,
finally.
Welcome to 2017 yeah.
He would say,
I don't even need,
I could,
you can't even store anything on this
piece of shit.
What are you doing here?
You can't even put a file on your
desktop.
Stop pretending that's a computer.
Got a goddamn computer.
Fuck.
It's weird.
Right.
People in their ipads,
he was a door guy.
Yup,
exactly.
Yup.
I mean there's a,
he's one of the best examples of a
recent graduate because he wasn't a door
guy that long ago.
No,
not at all.
Tony's always had his fucking nose to
the grindstone but really smart about it
to really,
I'm really good with like taking apart
his act re retrying things in a
different order slip and new stuff in
there.
You know,
it's cool to like as a guy like you
working,
you know,
as you're sort of,
uh,
getting everything going and working at
a place like the common stories,
you get to see a bunch of different ways
people do it,
which is really like that main room show
on a Saturday night when you're getting
to see,
you know,
five,
six,
seven headliners in a row and you get to
see what's the difference in how they
handle things and how they set things
up.
The nine o'clock spot,
the nine,
15,
39 45 you're getting like this crazy
education and stand up.
Yeah.
I mean I watched people,
I mean it's cool cause I've got to see
the different careers and paths with
people like watching Brian Moses go from
a door guy to the host of his own show
that he created along with a lot of
great people,
you know,
the community.
Uh,
and just to see him do that and to see
where his career is going and also to
see Tony,
same thing,
his career and just the path east
taking.
And you know,
he also,
you know,
you used to write for Jeff Ross and all
these things and you know,
I got to ghost write to send jokes in.
You know,
that was something he also taught me
about was that he was just like,
you know what?
He was just like,
there's nothing,
you know,
he's like,
when you know those roasts are coming
and he's like,
you've already done the roast battle.
He's like,
just start pitching jokes.
Just ask.
You know what I mean?
And I did.
And that's I think what also helped get
me on the radar.
Yeah,
for sure.
it is beautiful to see God like Moses
get to host a show too.
He's such a good
dude.
He is one of the best dudes.
Uh,
and I owe so much to that guy because he
was the one that pushed for me getting a
job.
He was the one from,
it's really had my back since day one.
Um,
there's,
there was a few times where it just,
me being a young guy and having a
bitterness,
like when Montreat when roast battle
first one to Montreal,
I was like,
yeah,
we'll just young and bitter and cause I
was just like,
oh,
I'm not going well you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
I work on the show and I almost quit.
And then Moses was,
if he wasn't like a big brother,
he like took a person,
was just like,
Nah man,
stop fucking being a bitch.
You know,
he's like,
you can either get mad or work and get
better.
And I did.
I stayed and I just kept battling.
I kept doing standup and then the
opportunity came and knocked it out of
the park.
Yeah,
dude,
you killed it.
You killed it at the perfect time.
Yeah,
the launching pad of crying God studio
and,
but I,
it's like song.
I couldn't have done it without all
those guys.
Yeah,
no,
and I'll sure you pushing me too well,
all of us together.
You know,
I really do honestly get inspiration
from looking at your instagram page for
real.
Not bullshitting at all.
I see your instagram page,
I'm like,
damn,
this kid's hungry.
He's out there grinding,
you know,
constantly doing spots.
Those hotspots.
What was you telling me that too.
And also it was like,
just listen to you talk about those
lights,
but it's also hearing you talk about
having to go up after prior,
especially if such a hard time for him
and like having to do those things and
it was like five weeks.
Yeah,
man,
that's crazy.
Yeah,
it was.
It was the sad era of prior went before
he died.
He was in real bad shape,
but he still wanted to go on stage and
he would go on stage.
He was under medication,
you know,
it's a serious issue.
He couldn't walk and they would carry
him up there and they'd crank the mic
like shh.
It was so loud.
It was like hissing in the room and he
would,
you know,
he could barely talk and he would drink
and,
and it was just real weird,
you know,
it was real weird.
He just,
he couldn't,
couldn't really do stand up anymore.
I couldn't really look form the
sentences with the punch lines,
at least not in this sets that I saw.
Every one of them that I saw was hard to
watch.
And I'm a giant Richard Pryor Fan.
I mean,
I think he's,
he's probably the all time,
number one in my eyes.
I think he's number one.
If I look back at like all the comics
and their influence on people and the
honesty that he had on,
I mean without Lenny Bruce,
there's no one right.
But essentially,
and George Carlin plays a giant factor
there too.
There's a lot of guys that play a big
factor,
but I feel like prior was the guy to
this day,
I'll go back and watch his stuff when I
go in 1975.
This was just genius.
You look at everything that was going on
in 1975 he came out as a comic,
right.
Was just,
you know,
and that was the thing like everybody
loved prior,
every black people,
white people,
people are the rich people that were
poor.
And that's the thing that I liked the
most about him was like,
he could talk about these subjects and
these jokes and it didn't matter what
kind of background you came from,
you could relate to
hundred percent.
And he was,
he was,
uh,
you know,
essentially
the godfather of this style of standup.
They,
both you and I.
Do you know when,
a lot of ways,
like without him,
like what would it have been like back
then?
You know,
like who else was like,
even remotely is controversial and as
insightful and the way he could perform,
the way he announced,
he hated his words.
I mean he had some fucking bits.
They God damn camera,
which specialist?
I think it might've been
the first one.
He like,
it shows him walking out on stage.
The lights are still up,
people aren't fully sat down at their
seats and he just walks in and says,
all right guys.
And he just starts getting them to come
in and you're just like,
yeah,
wow.
Hill.
And he'd just get,
it's like,
I think,
I don't know if he gets right into it,
but he just,
you know,
it's seamless,
to to remember him
would joke about lighting himself on
fire.
So funny,
right after the freebasing thing
happened,
I mean,
come on,
who has the balls to joke about lighting
themselves on fire from Free Basin?
Like,
uh,
when peewee Herman came back out after
that huge thing happened and he walks
out and I think it was like the first
thing he was hosting right afterwards or
something or presenting and he comes out
and he goes,
it's dead silent.
People are like just kind of looking at
him and his right after he got caught
and stuff and he goes,
he goes,
you guys here have a any funny jokes
lately.
And it was right at the time that
everyone was cracking all those a herman
jokes about him being with thing and it
was just,
you know,
someone that can take some of that could
be serious and then
still
humanize themselves in a way like that.
And I think that's why the roast battle
so cool.
Cause it's like you're right.
Yeah.
Learn how to take what to write.
Not just dish it out but take it.
Yeah.
Peewee Herman.
Man,
that was a really fascinating one.
Okay.
Cause people kind of stood up for him
like,
yeah.
Like leave the fucking guy alone.
Like no one's angry at pee wee herman.
You'd have to rest them at the shit.
Of course he was beaten off.
It's a bunch of dudes fucking a 16 foot
screen.
Yeah.
What did you think was going to happen
but shit.
The rest of the guys that aren't beating
up.
Yeah.
No Shit.
Right,
gagging on each other,
fucking pounding each other on the
screen and he's not supposed to beat off
what's he supposed to do?
Right?
Yeah.
Fuck.
Leave 'em alone.
Who are you saving?
You know other dudes in there watching
people.
Fuck yeah,
exactly.
They feel threatened.
I want,
I like to watch people fucking art form.
I just imagine some dude.
Yeah,
I'm here.
Just some guys like getting ready and he
turns,
he's like,
oh,
she has it.
Oh Man,
I'm such a fan.
Do you think that's a crazy thing to
say,
but do you think that that would be
almost like,
like watching people have sex in another
time in another culture and another way
could almost be like an art form almost
be like a,
an expressive art form.
We're like,
if people fucking onstage was like stand
up and let people went to watch these
two people wanted to see how good you
fuck.
Oh,
that would be helpful.
Moves.
Like if if sex wasn't super taboo.
Yeah.
I get to entirely possible people would
be fucking in front of each other.
Like to show how you do it.
Just like how people show high dance on
the dance floor,
the dance by herself.
You're fucking doing break dancing and
spinning around.
I just don't know.
Now I just imagined there's just smaller
open mike communities of La,
like people fucking in front of other
people.
It's just like I just,
I'm working on this hot fuck move for
like a minute and I just feel like it's
going to kill dude.
This one fuck move.
I got to pee.
I kicked my one leg up and I catch it.
Like I'm in standing bow pose and I just
booked,
been behind,
kills the crowd every time.
Could you imagine if there was
professional fuck shows and like people
got cheered like Tang Po and fucking
kickboxer that walk out.
Everybody goes crazy.
Did you see his and hot new hour?
He's,
yeah,
he knows how to fog
standing ovation while this dude's just
finished.
Yeah,
I mean sex is obviously it's pleasurable
but it's also,
there's motion involved.
There's a lot of things that we watched
with motion involved at other people do.
That's fascinating,
right?
Like gymnastics,
gymnastics.
There's no,
I mean the only stakes are don't fall on
your head.
Yeah.
You've seen people do that.
Don't break your leg cause we've seen
people do that.
Like those stakes are really high.
But other than that,
like you know,
why are you really doing that?
You're doing it to show how you move.
Yeah.
You know my favorite is like,
cause it starts with guys like exactly
what you're describing.
I think for real.
Oh no way.
Sex Festival in Europe.
Oh my gosh.
Salon Erotico de Barcelona.
Jesus Christ.
I saw an article in vice where the
someone,
a bunch of people,
what
they're taking,
they interviewed people that were taking
photos at the thing and what they'd like
to do at their photos and how creepy
they are not going to be.
And they're all seem pretty crazy.
This quote out.
It's the feeling of in quotes,
I was there,
I was inches away from it.
I touched it.
That makes looking at my own pictures.
More exciting.
Alright guys.
Just taking photos of these people
having sex super up close.
I see.
It's crazy.
That dude's got like a Gopro.
I love it.
And like you look how expensive that
fucking flashes on this camera on.
Ooh,
Jesus Christ.
That's what's that?
The photos look like just super up close
guys.
Just getting away.
My favorite is this dude right in the
front with the camp.
How weird are we?
That's so strange.
Yeah,
but I don't think really people just get
together and they know.
I mean it just humans collectively as
all.
Yeah.
They just get together and watch people.
Fuck,
look at this guy's face that his face is
the best.
Oh,
he's indulging.
That guy's been,
he's been kept from without for so long.
Just the look of joy on some of these
guys.
Like I don't think that guy in the
left's taken it seriously,
but I think this guy in the right is
totally taking all these people.
Every single one of them is just dying
for virtual sex to come out.
They're just dying to just dying for
that.
That's what's going to change the whole
God damn ballgame.
Frank.
They put those virtual htc vive goggles
on and they,
they watched sex acts like this.
They go,
they're alive.
They have like sex offs and shit.
Oh,
just wait until,
I can't wait to my girlfriend catches me
with one of those sex doll.
No,
no,
just like the vr thing.
Like I want to hear her come in.
Yeah.
That's plenty of guys that have done
that and been called for sure.
There's got to be,
yeah,
for sure.
Kaiser in jail for that.
I guarantee you something went wrong and
it all started off from them jerking off
the htc vive on.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
hits him with something and they throw
it back at her and she gets knocked out.
I told my girlfriend I wanted to,
uh,
when I get the,
cause they suddenly got the prize money,
but when I do,
I was like,
I want to just get it in cash and just
throw it at her.
So when she gets bruised she can call
the cops and they can be like,
what happened?
How did these brews come up?
And I'm just like,
it was approximately $10,000 in damage.
Uh,
she left but on pump,
you know,
taking her to Hawaii,
Hawaii's good spot.
Which island?
Maui.
I think now he's awesome.
They're all awesome.
The uh,
the big island is crazy because you
could actually fly over the volcano.
You can get in one of those helicopters
will take you to the place where the
volcano empties into the ocean and it's
like creating more island as you fly
over and you're like,
Whoa,
that's insane.
He sleep weird at night with that
knowledge.
Yeah.
Then it can just go to anytime.
You were on the side of an active
volcano.
Yeah.
Those people live there and harmony
though.
It's really interesting.
I think that being that connected to
nature the way they are because they
have the ocean there,
and not to say that Hawaiian people
don't have their problems,
like everybody has their problems,
but Hawaiian people have a more relaxed,
you know what they'll call like island
style way about them,
I think in some way is probably
influenced by the humility that you just
naturally get by being so connected to
nature.
The ocean right there,
the mountains right there.
It's just like they're so connected to
it since they're,
they're not,
they have never had city blinders on.
You know,
maybe a little bit in Honolulu,
people do,
but out there on the big island,
there's no city blinders man.
You're looking at something like really
insanely intense all the time.
Mountains and ocean.
It's amazing.
You're on a volcano sun,
it's beautiful and has a bunch of times
in history where the towns have had to
evacuate.
Lava is coming over the hill and it just
wipes out the whole talent town doesn't
even exist anymore.
Then Dude's put up these little shacks
on where the lava is and they rope it
off and that's like their land now.
Like they go back and land is like,
like gps doubt and they like put stakes
in and make like a little fence over the
fucking lava and then they put like a
house there.
Have you seen that Jamie?
See if you can find some photos of that.
It's,
it's so bizarre.
I was almost born in Hawaii houses on
the big island,
uh,
to like temporary houses in the big
island over lava fields because these
people,
they lost everything and they're like,
well,
this is the only thing I have.
It's just going to put a trailer up
where my fucking house is supposed to
be.
That's what happens.
Imagine.
Yeah.
Imagine just watching that go down where
your house burns down and you just like,
let it start over.
I think it,
why would they should have is land set
aside for people whose houses get fucked
up by volcanoes.
It happens all the time.
Yeah.
It seems like it would,
it happens enough where you should
probably have like a backup.
Maybe they do they have to have
insurance or something.
I think they'd probably have insurance.
It's gotta be,
have enough where they can relocate and
have a,
you know,
a house like their old house that got
eaten by the lava or is it enough to get
a shitty apartment?
You know?
I Dunno.
I Dunno how much they get paid,
but I would think that,
uh,
there's plenty of land.
What am I saying?
Well,
no,
Marxist won't give away their fucking
land.
Give away the land to the people that
want me to find temporary houses.
Right?
Yeah.
A temporary houses on lava fields in
Hawaii.
They staked it off,
I forget who showed it to me,
but they staked off their area and like
tied it off with like ribbon or
something like that.
And I'm like,
Hey,
this is my,
this is my land dunk.
Come,
don't come inside this lava pot patch.
I own it.
It just highlights how preposterous it,
it's,
yeah.
You know,
to live there,
but so awesome.
People will just stay there though.
They love it.
I went fishing last time was there,
I talked to this dude who had been
living there for long time,
decades.
He started out in the East Coast and uh,
you know,
the way he was talking about it,
man,
the way he was talking about just life,
I was like this guys,
he's so much more in tune with,
with like just,
just the reality.
I'm good dude.
Which suite?
The reality of life itself.
Just the cycle of life to see seeing it
out there on a boat in Hawaii,
pulling back into the doc,
living on this volcano in the middle of
nowhere.
I mean,
you're living in magical land.
Yeah.
People who daydream about that place.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They go there once a year and they just,
it just,
God amazing.
Did the guy lives there.
He got there and he was like,
fuck,
going back.
He was like,
Oh,
this is,
I could just stay here.
Fuck.
January in New York.
Like what?
My mom went there for her senior trip
and then when her senior trip ended,
she just didn't get back on the plane.
It's the move.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Not Quite but similar.
So this guy set it up on this lava
fields,
got a little house.
This is where my house used to be.
Yeah,
there was a whole a piece on it and
something that I was reading.
I don't remember what it was,
but it was just,
I get it,
you know,
and the guy didn't want to,
that was his spot.
He liked the spot and he could put up
temporary house there,
but it's just,
to me it's so,
it's just showing how powerful the will
of nature is.
This insane idea that you're going to
somehow or another state claim
circumvent pieces of above.
Haino look at that,
man.
We're just cutting through the
landscape.
Jesus Christ.
That's insane.
That's a road dude.
It just swamped right through that
place.
That is at that picture.
Go back to that picture again.
Oh,
look at that.
That's happening right there.
You could actually see it happening so
slow.
Have you seen videos of just lava taking
stuff out?
It's really slow,
right?
Yeah.
So how many feet a minute does it go?
Um,
and there's nothing they can do about
it,
right?
Nope.
They can't like push it though.
Look at that photo or that photo where
it's just cutting through.
Oh,
the one up right there.
No to the left of that guy with the red
shirt.
See the got the right to the left of
that?
Yeah.
Click on that.
Why in the fuck?
That's crazy.
We're looking at the actual lava itself
oozing and when you look at it as a
liquid rock,
like a hot liquid rock,
you realize what it really is like that
this is like sort of,
this is like the seeds of the,
the,
the actual islands themselves.
There's people who go to those places
and just get super close and study that.
That scares the shit anime.
They study it real close.
There's been a few scientists have died
from that.
I'm sure.
Can we make sense?
I think,
uh,
there was actually a famous one that
like,
uh,
oh,
what did he,
I want to go above.
There was no,
the one,
the one you were just your curse.
We wrote to the right of that,
right to the right of that.
What is that?
Whoa.
Oh my God.
That's a river.
That's a god Damn River
or river of molten rock,
of river,
of molten rock.
Just cutting through the earth.
Oh my God.
It starts way up there.
Oh,
imagine things lived in there.
Like Salmon,
like evil,
demon,
salmon,
lava sand,
and you have these fucking evil demon
bears at jump into the lava lake.
They can take a certain amount of lava
for like certain law and they're roaring
cause they're in pain and looking a
fucking team and fish to eat 10 meter
high fountain of Jesus Christ.
That's what the miners would create.
Does greedy,
greedy gold miners.
One of the,
if that thing hits you,
oh God.
Imagine like just a Blob of that hitting
your shoulder.
Fuck that.
Yeah.
Cause even the suits that the scientists
were when they go out,
that was like,
if a thing popped up and it hit them,
that'll eat right.
The room.
God Damn.
How credible that you can.
Uh,
you have a quick second.
It's not like hot coals quite,
but it doesn't,
it doesn't melt things as quick as it
seems.
Or maybe it doesn't ask Christ to come
to the creek to it.
Man.
These guys are standing right next to
it.
What the fuck are they doing?
I can watch this.
Oh,
that terrifies me.
it's just shooting out folks.
We're looking at stuff just shooting out
and splattering.
It's like the Earth's calming.
Oh Dude,
that's gross.
Oh,
how about this cooking steak with lava.
I've seen that.
That's pretty dope.
Yeah,
they pour it.
Yeah.
See they pour it through this thing and
there's a grill underneath it and uh,
the,
just the heat of the lava pouring under
the grill cooks it shit out.
He sticks.
That's pretty bad.
Yeah,
I bet that's a serious God damn stake.
Ooh,
look how he does it.
I was,
he taught and love on top of it.
Oh no,
he's just pushing it down.
I've revised my cooking methods.
Frank Castillo.
Ooh.
I used to cook with high temperature and
I just try it this last week with low
temperature.
I'm changing my game.
Low temps where it's at.
Do you cook?
Oh,
my girlfriend does.
I know how to cook it.
What do you know how to cook?
I know how to cook.
Like don't say Mexican Shit.
I know how to cook like steak,
some pastas and stuff.
My girlfriend's probably watching this
right now.
Like that's a fucking lie.
Shit Lib.
Like do you like if you're alone by
yourself to cook yourself a meal?
Uh,
most of the time now are,
I'll try to make myself a sandwich.
I'm the most unhealthiest person I gotta
I gotta get back into it.
Yeah.
You do do to help your brain too.
Oh,
absolutely.
Eating healthy,
being healthy.
It definitely helps formulate your ideas
and also it alleviates,
you have a certain amount of tension
that comes with you're a failing body.
Yeah.
I used to wrestle and do Jujitsu for
like two years out of high school and
that was the most fun I've ever had
because I wouldn't compete or anything,
but it was just like I could eat
whatever I wanted and I would still just
say the same.
I felt great about myself and it was
just,
it was nice while I started doing it
again.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna look into it right after.
We'll get you in a 10th planet Jiu
Jitsu.
Did you do it with the gear without
again,
I did it with a gay,
well,
if you wanted to do that,
there's John Junk Machado's that's,
that's close to.
I've been a metropolis.
It's great place and there's probably
somewhere near your neighborhood.
We'll talk about it off air.
It was probably even closer and probably
just as good.
There's southern California is like one
of the best places in the world if you
want to learn Jujitsu.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
So many legit schools.
It's like,
it's like there's two is really in this
country and there's a bunch of really
good schools everywhere in this country.
You mean Jujitsu is really widespread
but the meccas there's a a mecca in New
York for sure and there's a mecca in
southern California but there's like
Chicago
strong.
Yeah,
I mean this,
this strong Jujitsu everywhere.
Phoenix,
Arizona strong.
There's like a lot of places have good,
you're good too.
And I love going on Instagram and
watching the tournaments and just the
different people like boot Chacha is
probably one of my favorite ones.
Do you ever follow viral Bjj on
instagram?
You liked a picture of it and I started
watching it too.
It was great.
I try not to follow them too often.
Like to repost their stuff cause I want
people to go there instead of looking at
mine,
you know?
And maybe people find out about their
videos but they have the best collection
of like sick moves,
just sick like move after move.
We were like,
oh,
and you can add,
these are real moves that like,
I've been doing Jujitsu for a long time
and I haven't seen before.
You know,
I'm not the most knowledgeable guy when
it comes to Jujitsu,
but I know enough about it that when I
see some completely new choke variation
that I've never seen before and
everybody starts doing it,
I'm like,
okay that wasn't around like this guy.
This guy has come up with some new thing
and people come up with a new thing.
You know?
It's pretty regular.
Yeah.
That's my favorite rep watching
Jujitsu's.
You can just see people just the game is
always changing.
That's the best part.
Well you know what it is like man,
it's like the same thing with striking.
When you see it at its highest level of
expression,
it's when it's only striking.
Striking at its highest level expression
for me is either professional boxing or
professional kickboxing or Muay Thai.
That's where you see,
I think to me really I like Muay Thai
the best because it seems like they're
doing everything.
So if you're going to agree to just
stand up,
like I feel like you should be able to
do whatever you want to do when you're
standing up.
In terms of like elbows,
knees,
it doesn't make any sense to limit
clinching.
So I think that's like the number one
stand up thing as far as like what I
want to say.
But the only way you get to see like the
highest level of expression as if
there's no takedowns.
If this is no submissions cause then
cause as soon as there's takedown,
soon as their submissions guys have a
totally different way,
but as soon as his ground and pound guys
have a totally different way of,
of,
of competing and moving and you're not
going to see the same as high a level of
expression and just true striking and
the same as what Jujitsu.
Like you see a lot of crazy moves and
Jujitsu that me might not see if you had
soccer kicks or stomps.
You probably wouldn't for a lot of those
things because there's a lot of stuff
that people could do to mitigate your
movement that they're agreeing not to
do.
It's not that you're just totally
controlling them,
but to get the highest level of
grappling to watch it,
you really Kinda have to have only
grappling.
Yeah.
Cause then it's like these are rules
were agreeing to and then from there you
can really start to learn how to bend
the rules.
Yeah.
That's amazing man.
It's like,
it really is like when you were talking
about with the verbal boxing,
it's like that in many ways like this
strategy based approaches to things and
that,
that that happens with Jujitsu.
What happens with striking and it's,
that's what's really interesting about
martial arts more than,
you know,
like people look at it in terms of like
this,
you know,
uh,
exciting violent thing,
this Rah Rah Macho thing,
which is definitely,
certainly is.
That's definitely certainly a part of
the appeal of MMA.
But also what the appeal is,
is that it's insanely to do and you have
to be insanely brave to choose to do it.
For a living and in and it's,
it's insanely dangerous cause you're,
you're,
you might get shinned in the face.
You give my kid flying knee knockout
like you,
like there's a,
um,
a recent fight bitchin Chris Weidman and
Yoel Romero.
Did you see that?
Fine.
I saw a club Ood Weidman was doing
really well in that fight too and Yoel
Romero launched this flying knee that
hit him dead in the head.
She goes boom,
and just crushed him.
And I remember watching that going and
that's Chris Weidman.
Yeah.
That's not like a regular dude that's
former UFC champion.
Chris Weidman,
one of the baddest motherfuckers on
planet earth and Yoel Romero just did
that to him.
That does that.
That is a sport that is like no other
any given Sunday.
Man.
What are you gonna say?
Jamie George Saint Pierre signs to
return to the UFC.
Yeah,
I heard,
I was talking to my friend Stephie
Crooklyn from twitter,
a Steffi Hayes,
the writer,
and she was,
uh,
tell me about this.
She actually was the one to break the
news to me.
So George Saint Pierre is going to fight
again.
Good for him,
man.
It took some time off.
Chilled out.
Feels good.
It's still still training.
That's the thing about George never got
out of shape at all.
Constantly training,
constantly learning.
I bet he's better than ever.
Nobody comes back and people think that
he's going to have loss of step.
I bet he's better than ever.
Yeah.
He wouldn't be coming back.
He wasn't.
Yeah.
And I've been hearing crazy shit about
his grappling.
I've been hearing it's grappling.
So off the chain,
it was just a better than ever that a
underestimating someone is a huge
advantage and a tool we'll specially at
garlic,
George and George St Pierre did not
become George Saint Pierre.
Now by you know,
not knowing what's up,
he knows what he's doing.
If he's coming back,
it's because he knows he's healed up it.
Probably better than ever.
This guy is going to be really
interesting to watch him return because
he's different in the way he approaches
fighting,
I think than almost anybody before him.
And he influenced so many people after
him and that he's like almost has no ego
when it comes to,
um,
like listening to his coaches and like
absorbing information and uh,
you know,
being taught need you see him rolling
and training and drilling with people.
And I've had the opportunity to,
to drill with him and do some kick moves
with him,
go over some stuff and he's just so open
minded and so fucking smart.
That guy is a really interesting dude
cause he's not a mean guy at all.
He's like,
he would never think if you met him that
he was this world champion,
like one of the greatest,
if not the greatest,
I would say the greatest welterweight of
all time.
You know?
Does that mean that he would beat Damien
Maia a hundred percent of the time?
No.
Does that mean he would be tyron woodley
might not.
I don't know.
But if you look at his accomplishments,
he was in my opinion,
the greatest welterweight of all time
and super nice guy.
Yeah,
smart.
He speaks two languages,
fluent English and fluent French.
Really Fascinating Guy,
Matt.
So if he's,
if he's coming back after this amount of
time off,
he knows what the fuck he's doing.
Yeah.
He's gonna come strong.
He's going to,
he's going to look awesome.
Or you know,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
Also today,
a way drinks opened up from Mcgregor
Mayweather.
How can you do that if it hasn't really
been so fast?
It has to take place before May 31st,
2018 so like if it doesn't happen,
the batch just go away.
That kind of happens from time to time.
Like the card has to happen before your
fight for your bed to actually be legit.
But
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
I'll just say he opened up as a minus
2,525 to one.
I think it's Berto.
He opened up at minus 4,000 so I don't
know if that's saying that Mcgregor's
got a better chance to win,
but usually it's just set up 25 to one
is not so hot.
Yeah.
Mcgregor's plus 1100 yeah.
I think conventional wisdom is that a
floyd boxes the shit out of him.
But,
uh,
Teddy Atlas had something very
interesting to say.
He thinks that floyd is not recognizing
the fact that conor might just decide to
get disqualified.
That like if,
if it starts getting crazy,
like if they're in the middle of a fight
and he decides he can't beat him,
he might decide to just fucking flip him
on his ass.
Atlas Mcgregor would cheat against
mayweather.
Think proclaim himself as king of the
ring.
Hmm.
That's an interesting thought.
Well,
here's the thing.
If Mcgregor decided to start kicking
floyd and,
and decided to take him down,
floyd is a dead man.
Oh,
he's,
yeah,
he's a hundred percent dead.
There's not a thing unless he catches
connor coming in with the haymaker to
end all haymakers.
It can take that iris assassin out with
one punch.
Connor's going to grab him.
If he grabs him,
he's gonna rag him to the ground.
He's going to do whatever the fuck he
wants to do once he's there.
And if he doesn't do that,
it kicked,
come from the outside.
He can hit him from a place.
Floyd can't even touch him.
He'll just side kicked the shit out of
his legs.
He'll stay on the outside moving around.
Connor's a fast man.
He's not slow.
And in the first round in particular,
in the first round,
if he decides to start kicking floyd's
legs,
like if they agreed on that,
like some sort of a,
a Gnocchi versus Ali match.
Did you ever see that?
No.
In,
what was it?
1960s Mohammed Ali had a match against a
Enoki.
Who's this famous guy who was a pro
wrestler?
What does Antonio in?
Is that how you say his first name?
I think that's Antonio and Gnocchi.
Sorry for people who are big fans of
his,
he's awesome.
But uh,
I just forgot his name.
So he fought Ali and what he did was he
laid on his back and kicked Ali and the
legs.
See Ali would come near him and like he
was gonna Jab and a Gnocchi with look
like he was going,
I didn't have any gloves on either.
It was weird because I don't know if it
like what the rules of the fight,
where he goes.
It seemed like Ali's should have known
that this dude could kick his legs.
So boom,
see he would kick his legs and he kept
doing it over and over again and look at
Ollie's kicking him and holding on to
the ropes.
Like,
Nah,
you can't hold the ropes,
but you can kick the legs,
but you can't hold the ropes.
Like what?
Yeah,
like this,
I guess when
Ali was probably look at,
he's kicking the inside of his legs.
This is probably when Ali was band.
Does that make sense?
Is that when they did it [inaudible] 76
it said,
oh,
that's way past that.
Then I pass that.
That's crazy.
So this is must ben.
He just needed the money or they offered
him a shitload of money,
but this is when he was the heavyweight
champ then,
right?
Is that the case?
Was Ali the champ at the time?
Oh good.
He's kicking the fuck out of his leg.
Could just but scooting and kicking his
legs and looking to,
looking to get them in a leg lock.
It
just weird.
He's,
he was allowed to kick the legs.
I think we've talked about this.
They might've must have had some sort of
an agreement that it was okay to kick
the legs
is the reigning heavyweight champion.
Wow.
How nuts is that?
Okay.
6 million.
He was offered $6 million for the fight.
Whoa.
Oh Man.
Is that enough?
Yeah.
Well,
I don't know if he won.
Did he win or did he get,
that's the thing about boxing is the
rules.
Okay.
What'd you say?
Answer Mcmahon Sr was involved too.
That's hilarious.
Senior meeting,
Vince Mcmahon's
sold tickets to a closed circuit
telecast at Shea Stadium.
Two 30 shit.
33,000 people showed up for that.
Wow.
Of course,
of course everyone's going to want to
see him box.
So where does it say about the rules
like,
oh,
was you're allowed to kick the legs?
What does it say?
Yeah,
very.
There were varying rule or varying
claims over the years over what the
rules actually work.
It says no limitations on kicking or
grappling and all types of kicking,
throwing and grappling were allowed in.
The bell was the referee.
So Jean labelle was the referee.
Of course he was.
He's Jane Labelle.
Gene labelle's,
a legendary judo character.
He's awesome.
He's been on the podcast.
He's a,
a legendary guy in the world of martial
arts.
This last quote too,
from professional breasts.
Uh,
Brett Hart was working for Nokia at the
time and he claimed in an autobiography
that the black Muslims who are backing
Ali made it clear that if a Gnocchi laid
a finger on their champ,
they would kill him.
That's why Gnocchi lay on his back for
15 rounds kicking Ali in the Shin.
So not to use his hands.
Whoa,
whoa.
That's so he didn't have any gloves on.
He was allowed to punch it with no
gloves.
I said,
wow.
I mean it was allowed to maybe,
but he didn't.
But other forces outside and told him
that if they,
that's what it says.
Claim made by Bret Hart.
But you know what man?
Bret harts and entertainer,
isn't he?
Yeah.
He didn't like entertainers make
entertaining stories.
True.
Who knows?
That could be one of them,
one of them,
a plot lines,
you know what I mean?
Whenever you merge into the world of pro
wrestling and then another pro wrestler
tells you,
well,
I know what happened,
man.
The illuminati came down and gave him an
ultimatum.
Lose the match to the undertake or we
will take your house.
You know,
who knows,
man.
It's all a plot lines for those folk.
Where are you big fan?
No,
in high school I was,
oh,
come by you now.
My cousins were huge wrestling fans and
I was the smallest one that would always
get suplex to desat.
Cool.
Do they at least suplex you on the
couch?
Uh,
yeah.
Most of the time.
Yeah.
Tony Hinchcliffe still to this day loves
wrestling.
He almost took a job.
He almost took a job with the wwe as a
writer.
They wanted him to move to New York,
Connecticut.
That's where their,
their studios.
And he was like,
damn,
he loves it,
Dude.
He goes to those matches and shit and
goes nuts.
Cheers.
He's so silly.
Yeah.
They have,
uh,
they have,
they have a podcast and it's called the
four horsemen,
Tony and a few other guys.
They just talking about wrestling.
It's the best.
Hey man,
people love it.
I'll tell you,
people never got more mad at me than me
given tonio hard time for liking
wrestling.
Oh yeah.
God,
wrestling fans are dying were so mad at
me.
They were so mean.
I mean,
it's great though.
I had,
it was funny in high school,
man,
I'll tell you that I had a friend in
high school who was training to become a
wrestler and I remember people would
give him shit about it all the time and
then he was like,
no man.
Wrestling training camps,
no joke.
And then he came in,
he took his shirt off and he had just
bruises because I guess when they would
practice,
they would hit each other as hard as
possible so they know exactly how hard
it is that they're going to get hit.
You know what I mean?
So they can judge the palms,
we offer each other and they would just
practice that over and over and they
practicing all the falls and stuff and
like how to get it right and stuff.
But yeah,
if they fuck up,
they just,
they,
they really can hurt themselves,
you know?
Yeah.
They definitely can mean wrestling,
uh,
involves a lot of contact.
Oh yeah.
There's a,
it's so brutal on the body.
All those wrestlers that at some point
in time wind up getting badly injured.
Like Dan Gable was like one of the
greatest,
if not the greatest of all time.
He's got like all kinds of replacements,
hip replacements and all shit and all
that kind of crazy shit.
He just had this indomitable will that
sort of outran his own joints.
He loved entertaining the people.
Yeah.
He was an animal man.
That guy was phenomenal.
The movie,
the wrestler is more of my dad's
favorite movies and a mirror watching
that with them.
Me and my dad loved to go watch movies
get,
it's kind of like our thing.
So we bond and no,
I never saw that.
That was the Mickey Rourke.
I saw like a scene from it and that was
it.
I just never,
I always wanted to,
I never sat down and watched it.
I I,
it's so funny.
It was like,
I just watched a grown man cry.
Like I watched my dad.
Ah,
yeah.
Me and my,
my dad can't.
I mean I love my dad to best to death,
but when we watch like father,
son movies,
anything like that,
it's always a tear jerker for him.
Aw,
me too.
I'm the same way.
Oh,
that's awesome.
It's hilarious.
I couldn't watch pursuit of happiness.
Which ones that it was will smith and a
kid.
Oh,
when it becomes homeless,
fuck that.
I was like,
no,
you're not going to do that to me.
I'll tell you what.
I don't want to,
I'll give away a giant spoiler alert if
I say this,
but I tried to watch that movie that we
were talking about.
Uh,
the arrival or arrival,
whatever it is.
I tried to,
I got through the first hand.
I'm like,
fuck you
shut it off.
Not Interested in anymore.
You're not going to play my strings.
Ooh.
You're talking about with her daughter.
You fuck the figure out the movies.
Do you cry during Armageddon?
Just the asteroid and nope.
Nope.
Knew it was fake at all.
I knew the other one was fake too deep
impact.
That was fake as fuck too.
It was terrible.
Do you think that people from deep,
deep impact meet people that are fans of
Armageddon?
They go,
Oh my God,
I love you from that Bruce Willis movie.
You're like,
fuck you bitch.
Hey.
I was in the other one.
It came out a few months ago,
but we came out first.
We were at first armageddons bullshit.
Well,
he thought that Armageddon.
They had the idea first.
No,
no,
no.
That's propaganda.
That's fake news.
Fake News.
Bruce Willis,
man.
Yeah.
He just said I'm good.
Yeah,
stop.
Just chill.
Probably just go surfing and shit.
What does he do now?
Does he still acting?
Yeah.
What are you gonna say?
You were going to say something?
Spoiler alert.
Yeah.
I can't wait.
All right.
Keep your trap shut.
You don't want to ruin it for everybody.
Yeah,
he's always been like that guy.
There's like some dudes that get
attached.
It's just really kind of fascinating
when you think about how many people
there are and think how many dudes get
attached to like that action movies
genre.
Oh,
like Bruce Willis,
like boom,
die hard.
You know,
like he was the guy for the actual movie
snarky action star who figured out how
to save everybody.
Yeah,
that first diehard man.
What was the one?
The the one,
the football one with Damon Wayans right
above there.
That right there,
the last boy scout.
There was another one he did and he's
always just like troubled cop blend in
pizza up with milk for breakfast,
you know,
you know what I mean?
He's always that guy smoking a
cigarette.
Well,
I guess we're just going to have to find
out.
Yeah,
he was the same dude in 16.
Dude.
He's in a gang of movies like that.
At the same dude in um,
a pulp fiction.
Right.
He played that boxer dude.
He was great.
Hudson Hawke,
man.
Bruce Willis has been in some good
fucking movies,
man.
What was the one with the kid?
Oh,
is the kid.
No,
the one with,
um,
that's true.
There's a movie called the kid.
Uh,
he's a go mercury,
right?
Oh,
6 cents.
Yeah.
A lot of move with kids.
That movie was fucked up.
That was what movie was like.
Whoa.
What is this I think emanates coming
back.
Um,
I don't know about all that dude.
That village movie may be done with him.
I clean my fucking hands.
No,
I get it.
He's someone put it this way.
He's like m nights,
like the girlfriend,
you know better than should come back to
no better fuck her man.
I actually liked that elevator movie in,
in,
in parts.
I enjoyed the ride.
Did,
I didn't think it was the most
satisfying way to end it,
but it's hard.
How do you end in movie about,
you know,
evil elevator?
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
They did their best photo booth kept my
attention for a movie being in just the
whole time.
It's about a photo,
but it was that the phone booth.
So is that the um,
the Robin Williams won?
No,
no.
He's the crazy guy.
Who was the,
the photo guy?
That was a good one.
I was talking about how I met.
I met spoken stem.
It's a phone booth.
Oh,
Phone Call Collin farrel.
Colin Farrell was on the other day.
I saw it and I took my friend to see it
and they were mad at me.
It was buried with Ryan Reynolds and
he's buried in a cough in the whole
movie.
Oh yeah.
I never saw hard to watch.
It's really claustrophobic.
Fuck fat.
Not Interested.
I don't need to see evil shit to make me
feel bad.
Show me some shit that's not real.
You know?
I know like,
like when we're talking about Avatar,
like Steven crowder got upset about
Avatar wan Avatar.
It was like a propaganda movie.
I was like,
look dude,
that's an awesome movie about blue
aliens.
The movie was awesome.
They flew dragons.
I loved it.
It was in three d.
I got to see it in Imax.
That shit was awesome.
My mom was,
my mom does that too.
All the time.
She'll watch like she watches the Matrix
and she'll read into it too much.
It's like it's about China and American
war anti-capitalism movie.
I can't be here for this.
This is propaganda.
No,
it's a movie about big blue people that
fly dragons.
You fuck.
This is a wonderful movie.
This movie's fun.
People get so caught up in that though.
Oh yeah.
They don't want to support those Goddamn
lefties and their crazy ideas about blue
people.
The blue people deserve to live giant
blue people that ride dragons,
shoot bows and arrows.
That movie was the shit.
It was so good.
So good.
The only thing I'm bummed out about is
they're going to do a,
part two is going to be underwater,
so that means no bows and arrows.
That's bullshit.
I love heart pounds,
like bows and arrows better.
Man.
That was a bad ass.
My was a great movie.
I just don't understand people who
couldn't appreciate that.
I don't know.
I feel like it's one of the things where
like people just have gotten to this
point where they're like,
no,
I don't want to say my opinion matters
so much.
What?
It's like,
no one can just enjoy something anymore.
Everyone was asked to have either a
shitty opinion on it or like a really,
really not so shitty.
Well I see people use all sorts of
different things to sort of make their
point and I see if you were trying to
make your point about some anti
corporate movie like you would see like
this and say,
but I,
it's what I see is like dynamics that
make a good storyline where you're
invested in the plot.
I'm not looking at it as a propaganda
film because it's in fucking Spain's.
Yeah,
and they have floating islands and none
of that's real.
The dragons aren't real either.
It's not real that marine guys,
not a real person.
Like when people freaked out over the
star wars movie,
Oh it's so amazing.
It's not real.
What do you carry?
You fucks.
And people are getting mad that they try
to force diversity and the star wars
movies.
Oh,
when we go,
it's going to have the grill things.
You got to have the black guy.
He was a fucking storm trooper.
I see what you're doing.
Hollywood see we doing,
you're trying to fuck with what we like.
Try to take away our glory.
Glory of white people dominating science
fiction movies.
Has anybody dominated any genre more
than white people have dominated science
fiction movies?
I come to you.
So true.
I come to you with a sincere question.
He wanted to talk about a lack of
diversity.
Black guys in science fiction movies
have zero chance of survival.
It is like zero eaten first,
right?
That fucking dude [inaudible] alien.
That really cool black dude who got
sweaty all the time.
Favorite one.
He uh,
he got Jack Pretty quick.
He didn't make it very deep.
Didn't who got,
he didn't get killed first though.
I got second.
Did he get second?
Super Normal.
Like think of like all the big time
science fiction movies.
Dune.
Um,
well,
doom is a dean then you getting weird
though because that's the Rock Dune.
Doon Oh dude.
Yeah.
Those were all white people.
That's a good one.
That's a perfectly great one.
When they,
Paul Moody used to have a great joke
about this.
He used to have a great joke about a
Lavar Burton on star wars about they
finally put one on tv.
They make him blind.
Man,
I'm totally taking it out of,
you know,
cause he used a lot of n bombs,
but uh,
it was hilarious.
It's fucking funny and true.
It's true.
So Lieutenant Uhura,
she's basically a secretary stay very
desk co Captain Kirk's out here saving
the day.
You know what I mean?
That's really what it was.
Yeah.
I mean she would take the call,
sir.
It's the aliens are on the other line.
She was the one doing all the clerical
work.
Yeah.
Right.
You know,
she wasn't captain Kirk's equal.
Okay.
And as that cling on,
there's Lavar Burton was his goggles and
there's the cling on.
Now the cling on it's super
questionable.
Is that a black guy that has a terrible
alien thing going on in me?
Are we looking at diversity and did they
bounce off that guy in the far right and
making wider to sort of balance it out
because that guy's white as fuck.
Oh yeah,
he's supposed to be a robot.
Right.
But tell me you can make an android.
It looks exactly like a person,
but you can't make his face not white as
fuck.
That's ridiculous.
He's Goddamn hands are normal color.
How come you idiots only painted his
face?
It's also he paid his fucking hands.
His hands are nice and pink.
And it's also like,
why is the white guy so logical?
And you know the other guys just so he
comes from a race of like aggressive one
on the pop star Trek.
Super logical too though,
isn't he?
Yeah.
Lavar Burton was super smart on that
show.
Oh yeah.
Science fiction and black people.
What,
what else?
Alien,
the movie alien.
No black people.
Ender's game actually had a great
Allianz rather was anders anders game.
It was a,
if you read the book cause uh,
the other,
there's a lot of skepticism where his
uh,
politicalness lies.
Ah,
but they would say that's a word sir.
I know I made it.
Um,
they say that he references
a lot and um,
it talks a lot about like the Vietnam
war in the,
in the ender's game book.
Like they say that the certain races
that he's talking about,
he's like,
he alludes to them being like the
Vietnamese.
I think I could be making all this up
probably,
but Anders Anders Games are really good
movie.
But at the end of it,
it's all about like this alien race.
It's eventually coming to attack and
they have these kids do this game,
but the whole time,
spoiler alert,
they're actually fighting and they're
controlling the ships from Christ.
It's an amazing book.
Uh,
and a decent movie.
I actually haven't seen them all white
people.
Yeah,
but that was another other guy.
The Indian Fella.
What's that guy's name?
Oh,
that's Ben Kingsley is any English
Indian.
Yeah,
he just put county.
No,
that's,
that's what he is,
Bro.
Come on Bro.
That's how he talks.
He's an Englishman then,
right?
Isn't he?
Isn't he of Indian descent and somewhere
you ever see that one movie?
There was any plate.
This badass gangster.
It's a really good movie.
Yeah.
He's played a lot of really bad ass
games.
He played that just really nene gangster
was it say here?
Just English.
Okay.
Hmm.
So I'm making things up.
He damn play Gandy though.
No,
no.
Look at his name.
Born Krishna.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
He's Indian.
Jesus Christ.
Of course.
Um,
but what was that movie?
Go to that seat.
Find that movie that he played in where
he was born in Kenya.
Sorry.
Go to his movies.
Find that this one movie that he played
as a really obscure movie.
It was a really good movie.
We played a gangster.
He plays a drink.
Hitman,
I think in one movings.
Oh,
those his movies.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Like I want a lot of awards,
dude.
He's the best.
Go the filmography right there.
46 movies.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
he wasn't shutter island.
keep going.
Keep going.
See if I can find that movie.
Sexy beast.
That's it.
To your left there.
Right there.
Bam.
It's in 2000 great fucking movie plays a
psychopath and you would go,
what?
That guy?
That guy seems like so peaceful.
He fucking knocks it out of the park.
He's awesome.
So really,
really crazy movie.
Mad.
He'd played a fucking complete nut.
It was great.
Yeah.
I like an actor that can play a villain
that's plays it so well,
but I'll still hate the actor
afterwards.
Yeah,
no,
I know what you mean.
Yeah.
Well that's the weird thing about
watching an actor,
right?
So you're agreeing,
you know that that's Tom Cruise.
You're agreeing that he's on a space
ship and he's targeting,
you know,
you can like the day after tomorrow is
that tomorrow movie because they have to
mine,
they changed the name to it's day after
tomorrow and it's like a weird subtitle
on it too,
which is in my opinion,
like one of the most overlooked science
fiction movies ever.
It was a brilliant,
oh no,
that's a edge it tomorrow.
Tomorrow.
That's right.
Edge of tomorrow.
Which one would have to tomorrow?
I was like,
what did that one?
Yeah,
that was the ice with the Quaid Fella.
With the Queen Fella.
Yeah,
that was,
that was a super bad movie.
That end of the world movie.
That was so bad.
I love bad movies too.
Cause then you usually laugh at them all
the day after tomorrow,
right?
That's what it was called.
Live,
die,
repeat.
Oh,
yeah.
Okay.
That's a great science fiction movie
now.
And it is white as fuck white people,
white people,
oblivion.
I think our eyes Elysium sorry.
Yeah.
Elysium yeah.
Uh,
Tom Cruise did that movie edge of
tomorrow and then he also did a
Bolivian,
I think like within months of each
other.
Wow.
Oh yeah.
They probably were confusing as fuck.
Right.
They're both science fiction movies.
Mm hmm.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That was a good way too.
Yeah,
man.
This,
there's been some good ones.
But with a guy like Tom Cruise,
like when you watch it,
you know it's Tom Cruise.
I mean,
that's a,
it's a weird thing that we do.
Yeah.
We know.
That's Morgan Freeman.
There's Morgan Freeman.
I know it was Morgan Freeman,
but I'm gonna pretend that he's this
dude who runs this planet and he wants
to talk to Tom Cruise.
All right,
man.
I gotta wrap this bitch up.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
We're supposed to end earlier.
I had a meeting that I blew off.
Oh,
no way.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to make some adjustments
now.
I didn't realize we were talking so
long.
I thought it was 1230 and it was a one
30 I didn't mean to crowder.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
Good Times.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
It's always awesome having you at the
store and always awesome.
I'm glad we're doing these shows.
It's be with me this weekend,
tonight and tomorrow in Oxnard,
so find people of oxnard tonight and
tomorrow.
It's uh,
Ian Edwards,
frank and me,
and we'll see you there.
All right,
see you later.
Okay.